I'm here to share with you my knowledge
of the game of chess it's not just
checks and attacks you have to be
creative check and now we can look at
few studies when changing pieces could
lead to a decisive advantage for one
side or to be a defensive mechanism to
save the game that looks otherwise
desperate why does an extra piece but
our poon is under attack and our mic is
under attack in the middle game or in
the opening you definitely have to pay
attention to this threat because night
is more valuable at the pool but with an
endgame so protecting the night doesn't
do us any good if we protect the night
and black takes the pawn that's a
theoretical draw position rook and
Knight cannot win against alone but how
can we benefit from keeping this pawn
alive a trick is that we play quiet move
a3 doesn't seem logical black simply
takes the knight with a check but then
King b2 and surprise surprise the rook
there has so many moves cannot avoid the
exchange Krug's goes back on h1 or g1
the loop d1 will change rooks and our
poem is unstoppable but instead of
moving to the first rank
h1 or d1 like who can go back a 4 and
then we understand why our poor moved
down to a 4 but to a3 sometimes very
important you make just a small move one
square but
it has devastating effect because this
poem protects square before and after
loop III check King goes on c2 or a -
doesn't matter then we'll go before and
rook black rook is trapped technically
is not trapped because like an exchange
you either take one before and after a
before out one is unstoppable or moving
crew kanji for and then after exchange
our points again stop and that's one of
the lessons of this endgame
what lessons will we learn today
grandmaster robert hess with me for the
magnus carlsen versus alexander Grichuk
semi-final of the 2017 speed chess
championship it's getting bigger and
better every single round Robert both
the players are sitting and waiting and
ready how excited are you to get this
party started well Danny I'm absolutely
stoked last year these two an epic clash
and yes Magnus Carlsen won by a large
score but Brooke actually was pretty
much dominating in the early sections of
that match and he slipped up I remember
a really bad tactic that he overlooked
and of course man was pulled away in the
bullet portion so I think will be a
close match much closer certainly than
magnus carlsen force Wesley so shout out
to Impala 1-0 who's already subscribed
and the show is just getting started but
it started with 16 everybody those
amazing and brilliant 16 faces you see
in front of you some of the best chess
players in the world it was cut down to
eight in round two the matches were
bigger better and just even more scary
these guys looks it looks like their
faces get more serious as we go on and
now we're down to four Magnus Carlsen
versus Sascha grishnack right here right
now today Sergey Karjakin versus Hikaru
Nakamura likely for December 15th
there's the bracket as it stands and as
I said very likely sucker Sergey
Kuryakyn and Cara Nakamura for December
15th that date could change but mark
your calendars for somewhere in the
middle of December all of you fans
robert the the show is about to get
started
shout out once again to our our sponsor
masterclass as of today if you sign up
early at masterclass comm slash chess
for Garry Kasparov scores with
masterclass you can actually get the
entire course now it is ready Robert it
is out so I know you've been sitting
there waiting saving up your money it's
time for you to go pull the trigger and
get yourself garry kasparov scores yeah
absolutely you know me Danny I've been
reading my great predecessor in
anticipation for the full masterclass by
Garry Kasparov well the game should be
getting started here any moment and and
just like that we are off to see the
Wizard the one before one of
wizard of magnus carlsen and his cloak
today he brings out the headphones and
the hoodie he's leaving right after this
to go join Eminem in an underground rap
circle in Detroit I don't know if you
knew that Bobby but that's what he's
doing right after this match so there
you go I thought he's doing in Carmelo
Anthony and OKC cuz hoodie Melo hoodie
Magnus is a perfect fit that's right but
no with the match underway I always
forget that we last year the 960 came
first but this year just regular games
until the 960 and we Siegrist shook get
off to a pretty solid start not a huge
opening theory whatsoever in these lines
the Kings Indian attack but probably goo
sugars trying to build up an initiative
keep the tension and try to outplay
Magnus in the long run yeah this is
gonna be interesting if we see this
repeated approach I don't feel like the
Kings Indian attack was something that
Grichuk played consistently last year
against Magnus you and I had the call
for that though we both admit that our
memories are not that good maybe your
memories but I don't remember all the
openings we saw that day when grishnack
and Magnus went at it but I do remember
what you said Sascha Grichuk jumped out
to a big lead in that match he was
actually up to Oh to start and
maintained and really out as you said
outplayed Magnus in the blitz portion
until Carlsen showed showed his class
and bullet but we earlier this year
Robert we saw Sascha against Maxine
Vashti lagravis wretch out some of the
ending games in the three-two portion
really trying to put himself in a
position to not let the bullet decide
the match knowing MBL's a better bullet
player I'll be interested to see if that
plays a factor today if he jumps out to
a lead against Magnus look for Grichuk
to take away take away time off that
overall game clock remember everybody
that's one thing that makes this format
different and interesting and more like
other sports you're not just raising the
score you're racing against a clock
which is not something they normally do
in a regular tournament so shall I once
again to gummy bear
gummy bear man oh one for subscribe to
our Channel your thoughts Robert on on
that match strategy potentially coming
from Sasha well he definitely said to
better in the longer time to chose
because as we saw last year Magnus
completely dumb in him in the bullet
portion I believe Maggie's only at one
point heading into the bullet and then
ended up winning by eight
so clearly not cook strong suit but in
on the board chess rook has several
80-plus move wins against Magnussen yet
the lot the more moves these games have
the fewer actual games at this time
control so you know if Christian is
gonna stay in the match he needs to jump
out to a lead hopefully he's in
practicing his bullet and right now I
you know his position actually I don't
particularly like I mean Black has done
well to not just equalize but after this
move castle right now I see absolutely
no issues whatsoever for black White's
pieces are a little strange yes you know
why he's expanding on the King side here
but after Bishop g6 you know f4 it's not
like this bishop on g6 is actually
getting trapped unless I'm overlooking
some sort of tactic I guess either
Bishop g6 f4 you can't go f5 for black
because Queen e6 check that Bishop over
there on a d6 but wow look at that move
Danny rook e8 the Oh actually I'm now
I'm not sure about this what if I just
take this Bishop on h5 you do discover
with Knight g6 but I take the rook on
the 8th Queen takes the eight and then
pawn takes g6 what seems of a lot of
material for the sacrifice Queen yeah
after Knight takes f5 at the end of that
line white officially has a rook and a
couple minors so I'm curious to see what
happens here or what what Magnus
evaluates about that position Wow
90 Knight to c8 unleashing the Queen to
hit the knight that's my vicious Bishop
g5 is just good for what I think because
it hits the Queen on d8 and oh it didn't
play it but okay mr. G 585 maybe there
was f6 but that's a move you want to
entice from White's perspective cuz then
even even then you go Bishop back to e3
actually and then h4 is under attack
so dude they just miss up what seems to
me like a straightforward tactic or am I
just overlooking something this early in
the day uh you know I I would be more
likely to believe believe it or not that
that they're missing something than you
at this point I know you ate your
Wheaties this morning and I'm not
worried about your calculate it's
interesting I don't know it's one of
those things we have to look back and
you know take it take a look back at
here comes the the knight in to e5
though with the transition that happened
whether Grichuk missed a chance
not we're liking black again I believe
look at this move 95 for King the Queen
and the pawn on d3 and if this black
Queen gets to h4 it seems like blacks
pieces are naturally finding good
counter play on the Kings side yeah
absolutely I don't even see a way that
white protects is pawn to c4 because
I've your queen d4 that's a terrible
square for the Queen the knight just
comes see seven over to f5 and blacks
initiative is huge over there on the
Kings side with the white pawn structure
very strange e double H bonds and just
an F pawn so now just pawn 64 it looks
like a free pawn
yeah Magnus calculating there we see
some some RCM rapid calculation movement
there from the eyes I think Magnus is
considering whether he wants to take it
or maybe even just go I move like d4
keep the position closed and and and try
to focus in on the King side as much as
that seems weird I wonder if you could
play d4 and and keep the d3 pawn
backward and then kind of build up on a
King side attack so we'll see if Magnus
decides it's better to take the pawn or
to keep the position closed and try to
go for a king set attack yeah I guess
I'm being a bit greedy at the moment I
just don't see any way to kind of rebut
my plan of just DC for DC for Knight
takes d4 but I agree with you Danny that
actually a black had played d4 there
there's this weakness long-term we use
on d3 the 95 is in prime position I
guess there perhaps why we've attempted
to go f4 f5 very quickly and you know
that's white only real play is an attack
on the Kings side however for the time
being black king is perfectly safe
because there's no way there was no
conceivable way at the moment for that
Queen to get to g7 and deliver a
checkmate and the only other thing that
y can do is really go b3 Bishop b2 and
then you know try given diagonal but I
think it's very slow after b3 there's
always going to be problems in the
diagonal from white perspective as well
because move like Knight to d3 will be
quite annoying yeah that would be a
brute force way to take advantage of the
rook on a1 with a piece sacrifice as I
show your analysis on the analysis board
but alright well either way Grichuk
knows he needs to do something quickly
decides to sacrifice the c4 pawn just to
get developed now officially down upon
and that h6 point is even potentially
weak
for for white in the long run but but
does he have some compensation now I'm
looking at a move like Bishop g5
potentially coming for white and maybe
trying to get some some access into
these darks we're starting with f6 yeah
that's a good strategy perhaps you can
trade the Queen's Bishop g5 and like you
said try to go through f6 the main issue
I see from whites perspective is the
form of compensation that you need is
very quick play and a huge initiative
I'm not really seeing exactly how to
make that even if you get the bishop off
three five now if I go Knight f6 check
at some point and trading it off I just
think that you're down upon and
especially as Bishop on g2 is staring at
a rock the 7th pawn structure is it's
you know blunting that Bishop quite
frankly and so I don't really see the
full compensation from the pond
especially now I think black can only
just move f5 here and that kicks the
night away from you for it's sometimes a
risky move but with black with much
better development I don't see how white
is going to fight back against move like
f5 yeah I like f5 too I think
f5 obviously we have to look at the most
aggressive move Knight c5 and then
what's the move even to move like Queen
e7 right hit the knight on c5 protect
the pawn on b-17 and get back to work
with a move like rook to d8 coming to
follow it
yeah and White's pieces are just not on
particularly good squares and as bishop
must see one is stuck at home so you
know it looks a bit threatening in a
sense with his night on g5 I don't like
that move Bishop takes me to yeah I was
I was not expecting that at all what is
his plan because by the way everybody
Bishop takes b2 Knight takes b2 would
fall to coin to c3 double attack on the
Knight and checkmate so that can't be
Magnus is planned what's he what's he
planning with Bishop takes b2 he must
mean take g5 right but even that going
to see free is super scary to me yeah I
don't like that I don't trying to see if
I'm overlooking something but you're
right damaged Bishop takes b2 and Queen
see very happening next no matter what
Bishop f4 Wow super strange whatever
both players calculated because the
evaluation bar agreed with you Robert it
did not like Bishop takes b2 from Magnus
and suggested Girish ago exactly the
variation you're talking about taking in
Queen c3 but but now that Gershon
played Bishop before it's back to loving
blacks position naturally yeah this is
up so much material that the only
compensation is kind of phantom
compensations yeah you know hope hopeful
chess essentially that black will
somehow go awry and all of a sudden
Akane will be checkmated because I mean
black is up so much material there nice
nights I'm b6 and c4 and it's a phantom
attack like I'm saying so yeah this is
over now he's completely winning at this
point yeah so how do you convert on this
I mean okay so h4 h5 this will be a last
stab here by grishnack potentially
really before yeah there's more this is
a perfect continuation here by Magnus oh
it's good yeah rook d1 is coming and
that's gonna force a Queen trade and
with it all your attacking chances are
gone once the ladies come off the board
white black is I think I can safely
resign here and not be a yeah I'm surely
Grichuk doesn't doesn't look super
thrilled with this first game here but
we will we'll see if Magnus converts it
cleanly or gives them any more chances
we only have not only we still have an
hour and 20 minutes left here in the in
the 2017 speed chess championship here
round 1 it's just 5 to blitz everybody
if you're just joining us we still have
a lot more to go so you didn't miss much
stay tuned you know when you said only
there you remind me of a teacher me like
oh we only have 90 minutes left in the
third period
it's only 90 more minutes right Magnus
going with Knight f3 and c4
interesting stuff this looks a little
look it's gonna reach something a little
more mainline the last Kings in the
attack by trick was not super
theoretical yeah and this is definitely
popular even at the highest levels and
exactly I would say it should be 5 by
Magnus is a good point it's that you're
putting pressure on this knight on c6
if black ever captures on d4 or even
doesn't black is up an isolated deep
pawn and white is happy to just are
putting pressure on it now black can
make a move here like a 6
but white should not capture on c6
misete retreat the bishop probably to a
four also consider going through you too
so you play against that isolated pawn
and that is White's main benefit in this
position so should black take back with
the b-pawn then right it's a transition
where you have to choose do you want the
hanging pawns where at the very least
they protect each other and you have
more potential for space ah but then
comes e4 right Magnus actually
immediately ready for that this is a
very common teaching moment here Robert
where you where you attack the lead pawn
in one of these hanging pawns structures
trying to get the trade to happen which
will force the c6 and a six-months to be
even weaker and even easier to target so
this I really like this efore move by
Magnus especially given that black
hasn't gotten castled yet and certainly
overlooked by Chris sure because the
bishop on d6 is hanging right so if you
ever take on e4 squeezings d6 and that's
problematic however I don't think the
black is are too poorly here because
even if you either go Bishop before
maybe Bishop e7 is a little more safe
but Bishop e7 and we all capture on d5
the Queen takes on d5 DN but these two
bishops
provide good compensation for the pawn
of course what it'll be slightly better
there but two bishops are two bishops
have a lot of open space to work with
and with only two on one on the Queen
side actually the black can equalize
without too much difficulty with proper
play yeah agreed with you and we'll see
now Grisham choosing the other move you
mentioned quickly Wow
he plans to castle after taking the pawn
similar ideas of what you're saying he's
shout out to k1 HKU and Sam Cooke opened
before for subscribing sorry I forgot to
mention you if white takes on c6 and
Bishop takes it's the type of
compensation you were talking about but
maybe even more aggressive for black so
much so that Magnus doesn't even want to
gobble the pawn yet he wants to increase
the pressure and see if he can get more
than just a pawn in the center here yeah
and it's very smart honestly because the
advantage that he wants is not
materialistic but instead he wants a
positional edge where he's playing a
knight and I'd have three against his
Bhishma and d7 and hoping using the
square in d4 which we'll call a transit
square and what that means that any of
wife P's can use it and not actually be
attacked so the night you come to d4 at
some point of rook can come to d4 and be
very solidly protected on the square
even now Queen d4 actually is a good
option
trying to shatter blacks kingside pawn
structure so that was very smart by
Magnus understanding that the material
advantage was actually helping black in
his pack in his quest to equalize
whereas this type of advantage become
much more difficult with many threats
down down line but in the end Magnus is
a material girl in a material world
Robert he is gonna have to try to go for
some sort of pawn right you're gonna see
the pressure on f6 mount to the point
where the d5 pawn is something Magnus is
still gonna be try to try to be winning
yeah I mean for sure but now with his
[ __ ] 26 is really difficult to actually
go for that pawn and I think there's
been I don't know if something feels a
bit in knackered the last few moves
because I don't I wasn't hoping for from
White's per se would take on f6 now so
he's like yes as it's being played the
rook is infiltrating via b6 but again
these pawns for white are quite weak
their Queen side pawns are not connected
so at some point I move that Queen at
five going into c2 will be a nuisance
and so you even rook c7 and rook up to
see a hitting c3 I just don't see how
white can claim a real advantage here
yeah agreed 100% I'm not exactly sure
what happened with the tension there
maybe Magnus overplayed with the move 95
the thought that this tension on f6
would would yield more of an advantage
but I agree right now it looks like yes
white is gonna be probably the first
home win upon whether that's the a point
of the D pawn but these see these C and
a pawns are just as weak and hard to
claim an advantage from white at all as
they head to the endgame and has moved a
five by guk he's clearly unwilling to
part with the pawn and after f4 of
course now you've to be very careful
about white threatening f5 however I
mean a move here like rook to b8 trying
to trade those rooks or I asked queen of
five runs right into g4 so that's not a
good so I guess in g6 is ugly so yeah I
don't like to move 85 it just felt it
felt a little bit slow there's a queen
of five instead of 85 was what I was
saying just getting the activity yeah I
liked it and I was highlighting it on
the analysis board I had a hard time
also believing that black wouldn't be
equalizing in that endgame but but we'll
see I mean one of the reasons that
Magnus Carlsen is so good is not just
the Meuse he's playing on the board but
his time management we
how good he is I'm rapping and blitz
Robert I mean you can look at look at
the time right now right he's almost up
two minutes on the clock and fun fact
about Magnus for those wondering we did
a little research robber before this
match on just how good is Magnus Carlsen
and rapid and blitz was just in the
month of November he has had a an
overall record on online and the st.
Louis showdown of 88.5 to 23.5 crushing
Wesley so Dingley Wren we're just doing
even more and more research after that
performance against Wesley so on
Saturday of how good Magnus is in this
format and in these faster time controls
yeah he's an absolute monster and just
hardly anybody could contend with him or
even come close to contending with him
rook is one of those players who has a
shot if he's on his absolute best form
and because he just so talented a world
blitz champion but right now I just like
Manx his chances not just because he won
the first game because I just don't like
the decision-making I'm seeing from
Russia I just keeps prioritizing
material especially in this game right
now he's out actually I think he's now
with the creon see - he's better because
that Bishamon he's he six I quickly find
its way to e4 in which case white better
be careful so maybe I'm gonna eat my
words but what I was going to say is
that I think Chris Sugar's prioritizing
the wrong things at this point he was
looking at the material instead of
looking at the activity and right now he
has found activity and look at him go
his I believe his advantage is quite
large here because firstly why Sonny was
threatening any pawns right and more
importantly this Bishop coming to e4 is
a deadly threat so and that's exactly
why Magnus places moved knight c6
everybody trying to prevent Bishop a5
via the knight East 7 check fork which
would simplify White's position and and
defend against the threat you're right
if what if black could get this Bishop
d4 that could be White's out very very
quickly and that would be a surprising
end of this game but what if black plays
a simple move here right like rook e8
just guard East 7 and you're even a move
like rook e8 Robert threatens something
like Bishop takes h3 in some positions
due to rook e1 checkmate coming so
actually I love rook e8 rook e8 looks
great because I was gonna say Danny and
because King is shown but I stay after
rook e8 if room b7 still threaten is 97
check Bishop takes the H through is
winning on
right rookie it was a nice move there
but black is still better so it mean how
is white gonna Knight e7 it's such an
ugly move to play because now your
knight is threatening you're starting to
a pawn at five at some point but that
night is weirdly placed on e7 and so I
guess a2 can a to be picked off here and
maybe then f5 it's getting a bit
complicated so I guess I have to be a
little more cautious and what I'm
suggesting here but perhaps even Bishop
f5 from black just I'm saying okay I
will trade the minor pieces but your
King on g1 is Leslie say it's in my King
on h7 and this is the downside of
playing will move like f2 to f4 earlier
is that your king is gonna suffer in
these positions with the Brooke and
Queen on the board so maybe Bishop c8
here is even better right because if ya
Knight takes Aiden is rookie to stuff
yeah I wonder if Knight take C it is
rookie to just winning on the spot right
heading over to g2 and forgetting about
the pony all the way over there on the
edge of the board I think I should see
it and Bishop f5 I think Bishop f5 would
be the simpler way to like LK and angry
she decides that's what he wants but I
agree with you I think Bishop c8 was
actually the strongest move there for
black but position the biggest issue I
have with black position Robert again is
on the clock that's what got me a little
bit on my tangent about Magnus Carlson's
incredible November shout-out to k1 SKU
who is cheered both a thousand and two
thousand bits so thank you for loving
the show and thanks to all of our
supporters and viewers tuning in no
matter where you are we also had a ton
of people playing guess the move last
game go to chess calm / live or click
those buttons right below the chest comm
TV player and you can try to guess along
with the players
okay so Magnus taking this approach he's
gonna try to go after blacks weak pawns
before his King gets into much trouble
but something tells me Grichuk is still
driving the driving the bus here maybe
queen g6 maybe Queen c2 still well so
quit your Queen d5 now pick up the pawn
and protect g2 which is essential and I
don't see how black is gonna keep the
Queen's on the board and in fact he does
not on this game should peed out into a
drawing brush I can fact offer to draw
okay and agreed so well that happened
quickly
yeah I mean that was very strange game
Magnus look better at first slightly
better nothing huge and I thought we
should did not do well to stifle that
have been just said he actually let max
his brains grow but all of a sudden max
went F for perhaps not seeing the
consequences of that move and he was in
a bit of trouble there and if we shook
had been precise and in fact I predict
I'd had more time on the clock so he
could have been more precise and Magnus
could have seen as I go down in flames
but now we see some kind of weird it's
gonna be a weird theoretical battle of
this moment I don't know the theory I
don't play this line but yeah this this
early b5 line is super super
double-edged for black but I don't know
the theory either I would be I would be
kidding myself if I pretended to have
something eligible to say right now who
are we kidding
but okay but I guess we're gonna learn
something and I can already say that
comparing this match robber to
yesternight yesterday's but Saturday's
match with Wesley so really night and
day in terms of the different approaches
by the two players if grishnack is gonna
stay in main line theory
Wesley played an Enzo Larsson ready kind
of hybrid deal and avoided theory all
day against Magnus but I I think Eric
Hanson and I were both a little critical
of that even though Wesley afterwards in
the post interview said he just didn't
think there's any reason to challenge
Magnus in the mainlines he knows the
multi well but I think a lot of people
feel like the opposite approach is
really the best way to challenge Magnus
and to go into some theoretical stuff
and see if you can catch him sleeping in
a line and and get some sharp tactics
what are your thoughts on on the
different approach in terms of how can
you possibly play and expect to beat the
best player on the planet well I think
saying that the other player knows more
than I do or knows everything is not a
sign of weakness that's that abuse too
strong but is a sight sign of
nervousness and if you're being nervous
you're not playing objective chess and
quite frankly that guide is redundant
because chess is objective if you're
getting all scared and nervous and
saying I need to switch everything
because there's a difference between
being practical and saying my opponent
is a very great theoretician and
Sicilians let me avoid Sicilian and can
do something else versus saying he knows
everything let me just play b3 on the
first
not only does he know openings he's his
forte is in these just random neutral
positions where he uh plays everyone in
the world yeah so I think a bad strategy
I think it's a sign of kind of you know
I said nervousness it's not good for you
and I think Chris shook is off to the
right start in terms of opening choices
this far
well Wesley or Eric and I also agree
with that that Wesley in some ways maybe
gives Magnus too much credit and okay
either way not trying to hash out the
past to beat up on Wesley or anything
else but talking about the approach in
this moment where I believe that
Grichuk is he's got a small edge here
and at the very least in these sharper
positions where if you don't know the
theory or if you're falling asleep or
Magnus's case last match watching a
soccer game of Real Madrid at the same
time you might get caught and lose a
game really quickly right so I'll be
interested to see and I would bet that
we see Grichuk try to be a little more
direct and use some real preparation
something about this game
Robert the fact that this is totally
different than the last game where
they're both using real time in the
opening tells me they may even be trying
to remember a little bit of their ideas
in this line well frankly I hate White's
position because there's a lot of pieces
you're up upon but it's opponent b6 it
should be able to be scooped up quite
easily and right now for example rub d8
the only saving move for white it looks
like is a 5 because that pin on d4 is
quite annoying and going a 5 hoping that
Queen takes only five and then you know
you can go Queen f3 for example and I
work on the eight is hanging but so just
simple moves for black it should be
seven follow that up maybe with knight
c6 once you regain his opponent b6 you
have the two bishops and open semi open
board and I think just superior position
so I don't love whitefish miios I'm a
little harsh
I think West Asian is okay it sounded a
little harsh I'm gonna be honest with
you shadow cheat on new dachi and our
last subscriber sorry I forgot to shout
your name while Robert was offering me
some teaching moments but no okay I
understand yeah obviously that the
bishop pair for black and certainly if
the b6 pawn doesn't become an asset it
can only become a weakness when it's
extended as far to the sixth rank but is
is rook d8 really that strong of a
threat I guess that's a question if
white is forced to sacrifice the e5 pawn
and and early
the the pin with a tempo doesn't that
also help white though because the Queen
on f3 kind of makes the b6 point a
little more dangerous and some of those
lines for sure but what I always hate
when I have these kind of structures
making this move e5 and then when the
Queen's get trade off it's very
difficult to protect it's overextended
and so if I'm from blacks perspective
going rook d8 and if weif cozy five to
em Queen to e7 following that up with
Bishop to d7 and again that natural
development but I will say is in the
interim the e4 square is nice for the
white knight if we can get there safely
and and this poem v6 can only be an
asset because it's an extra pawn but I
really I think forcing this move you
know ripped 845 from white is
strategically very good from magnitudes
perspective okay so let's analyze that
Magnus is obviously taking his time here
to try to confirm but he agrees with you
let's say e5 Queen takes e5 Queen to f3
from white with family kyani I'm sorry
I'm gonna go Queen back to e7 I don't
wanna allow Queen f3 and you know just
hurting my queen side so that's the
rugby okay but I guess my thought was
that of Queen e7 now maybe White has
Queen to g4 with threats of things like
94 Knight f6 and White is sort of using
that e5 pawn and the newly-opened
Foursquare to get an attack going yeah
no that that definitely is the drawback
of allowing for V 5 and you the knight
coming to e4
but what so he just decided to take on
c3 instead but now I feel like he has a
nice little b7 a threat I guess Cain's
you a 96 and yeah you can almost play d7
first if you wanted to get that bishop
to remove itself from c8 everybody
that's Roberts idea then you take on e6
and you've got a discovery on the newly
undefended night because the bishops not
there so I think both b7 and Knight
takes c6 seem to be threats also what if
I just play the simple rook to be one
guard the b-pawn threatened v7 and by
the way if rook b1 Bishop e7 I can still
go for this idea of Knight takes c6 and
now I haven't even given up the b6 pawn
that's true I guess I was concerned rook
e1 would be eight but I then you could
still do this 96 stuff anyway but yeah
this is I think an oversight on Max's
part perhaps he thinks that you know
once a bunch of pieces gets traded he
could still have good strong chance but
I thought he was better before I mean
I don't know I feel like just has to be
you know miscalculation on his part he
has spent a lot of time so it's unclear
to me what I guess he might have been
worried about what you're saying Danny
would be five Queen G 494 stuff but now
this is just a pawn so white is up near
pawn well
Grichuk is cashing in on that pawn he's
taking on e6 and expect the b7 pawn to
come next everybody shout out to casual
sax who just subscribed here comes Queen
takes d7 and the e6 pawn is falling with
check now do we trade Queens as white or
keep the bishops keep the Queens on the
board what's your advice for the for the
viewers okay yeah he already traded
Queens I was gonna suggest the same the
problem is that White's King could
actually become under fire with eventual
Queen g5 and not to mention the Queen on
f6 hit the pawn on c3 so here it's
actually more difficult for black to
attack upon on c3 because the bishop on
e6 covers that CH square so from White's
perspective now maybe start with pawn f3
to hit the [ __ ] 24 then that way you
can get your King out quickly
yeah f2 and your rook a3 is another very
natural move coming up to both protect
the c3 pawn and to threaten rook F 2 a1
apply pressure on that a pawn so I don't
know why it has very good winning
chances here I think from a practical
perspective that you know just a retreat
here like Bishop I might keep it this is
tough decision actually I've it's just
you can't go [ __ ] of h3 I guess Bishop
f5 will be played offering in exchange
because if those bishops are traded then
the rook the both black works will head
the C file so it's a trade of the a pawn
for the C pawn the three on two on the
King side would result in a theoretical
draw so from wife's perspective you do
want to keep the bishop in the board
which leads me to believe Bishop b3 is
probably best because after Bishop b3 if
the bishop removes itself from the b12
h7 diagonal then white and he plays
Bishop b3 so now yeah we're okay three
very natural so I'm really liking
White's position more and more because
again you have this past C pawn you can
easily apply pressure on a5 and the time
situation with both sides having under
two minutes I think that also favor
white in this case because it's much
more difficult to defend and to start
pushing forward yeah agreed and now I
wonder if white could just start
bringing the king up king of to King III
and why not go all the way to d4 I'm not
exactly sure if blacks blockade even
though everything's protected now the
Brooks both guard a5 the bishop on c6 is
protected but I wonder if white just
brings the king up and black can really
afford to hold ground the way he is but
time pressure will be I mean one of the
things okay Magnus was down a couple
minutes on time really and now he's now
he's back to being up and and Sasha may
be deciding he doesn't even want to risk
losing this game because of time
pressure I was I was paying close
attention to that because I think that
one thing we've seen Grisham do even
though he jumped out to a lead in the
blitz portion is overall Magnus is the
much faster player and so I think that
grishnack has a little bit of hesitancy
or a bad taste in his mouth from losing
some games under time pressure in their
last match just in just a hunch
yeah there's a very fair point because
you know he's the slower player he got
crushing the bullet so he needs to keep
time on his clock which he has not done
a good job of thus far and okay this is
a theoretical draw though you know I
mean I guess it's possible to lose but I
don't see Magnus losing this one we have
a few questions in the chat about Magnus
is hoodie some comments maybe we can get
a maybe we get Magnus as a Sith Lord
let's get a Photoshop competition going
on here right but fun fact about that
hoodie robert he wore it at the Isle of
Man and at the champions showdown in st.
Louis so that that hoodie whatever it is
maybe it's got a soft silky touch on his
skin you know how we feel about soft
silky touches maybe that's why he's
wearing it but yes that hoodie is is
becoming a regularly featured part of
Magnus's wardrobe yeah I mean I don't
know I don't comment on his fashion
style or anything that's my job you
focus on the chest yeah it looks it does
let's go to yet okay well right now the
black King is perfectly placed I guess
the only attempt white will have is if
somehow black doesn't know what he's
doing
okay I don't want to kind of make this
seem more simplicity that it is but the
problem for why is you
of his King to the fifth-ranked and the
only way to do so is your g4 f4 f5 so
the king comes over to age five but when
you do that the rook will come to a1 and
thread and rook h1 check so you you
cannot get two pieces of taggings on
page six if that's the case and even if
white goes G for it and pushes the F
pawn you're not gonna actually be able
to make progress as black will harass
the white came from behind so this is a
well known theoretical draw and you know
if you add g3 g4 g5 try trade the G
pawns
well rook against Brooke and F pawn
versus rook is also an easy draw so I
think that in I mean I guess skews if
Danny I guess my question is if you're
Bruce shook do you actually want to play
this out or do you want to get more
games in the five-minute portion so that
you don't have to get to the bullet
portion you know with you rack before
bullet it's a good question and we
already know that Grichuk has maybe put
even more thought into the overall match
strategy of this format then maybe any
of the other players we've ever had
played right I mean he talked a lot
about that effort vtmb yelled everybody
you can see there was 58 minutes
officially remaining in the 5-2 portion
so we know sasha thinks about that I
would I would say it's twofold Robert I
think yeah I think Richards best chance
is the longer time controls to get a
lead in the match but you have to play
out positions where you're better
against Magnus Carlsen cuz last we
checked you don't get many of those
right so it's not to say that Magnus is
gonna mess up this endgame and throw the
draw but but he might right and you're
not gonna have a lot of chances to grind
him out and and win a game we're under
time pressure it's a lot easier to be
the person with the better position than
it is to play the worst position when
you're under time pressure right yeah
that's perfectly true I just think that
you know for example we have Chris
Sugar's were the black pieces he would
draw this with his eyes closed and it's
right right recognizing that it's just
my v h5 draw ok Magnus sees it and it is
a draw Nietzsche the draws offered not
yet I was just saying that that was me
that was me looking into a crystal ball
but okay there we have it and it will
show that we still have a one-game leave
for magnus carlsen if you're just
joining us Magnus won the first game in
this match but since then we have had
two peaceful results and dance a
shout-out to Busan G for getting 25 out
of 49 as the top guesser and guess to
move there that was that's actually
quite impressive getting over half the
moves right yeah I can't remember it I
got half of anything right now last time
very good wow that is pretty good yeah a
lot of people playing guess the move
log on to chest coms live server and
play the move on the board before the
players do and and you will be it'll it
tracks and lets you know how you're
doing kind of fun stuff there's also an
extension pole here on Twitch if you're
watching a twitch TV slash chess you can
vote on who you expect to win the match
most the votes leaning Magnus Carlson's
way but okay we have another not as
sharp as the last one we saw here is
white but still still a theoretically a
decently known theoretical position here
right and before black had gone d5 the
pawns of a 5 and see if I might have
seemed a little strange because it
creates a hole on d5 but the best way to
shore that up is by trading this
backward D pawn for that C pawn so now
black is sitting comfortable for the
moment with this 9 f c7 that can
eventually go to e6 and importantly
black of stopping Y from going d4
anytime soon and so it's gonna be a slow
kind of methodical game here where both
sides are trying to build up a plan from
White's perspective you're trying to
break through a d4 at the right moment
again it's very very difficult with this
the pawn structure b5 c5 and c6 and this
is why I'm moving a3 is played hopefully
hoping to eventually play before that
doesn't look very plausible but also
stopping the knight from going to be for
to be a nuisance on the White Queen so
if I'm if I'm black here I consider a
variety of moves where Bishop e6 is the
most natural I was gonna say g6 can
sometimes be considered to put that bish
one at five
but again black is doing very well here
very calm
and so you know I think that Greece
shook is should be very happy with its
current position yeah I'd say it's it's
the kind of more oxy bind you normally
see with white wear with the color is
reversed right white having this type of
structure the Marazzi buying everyone
being this pawn structure here where
black has more space and as long as you
can keep control over these breaks d4
and b4
you're usually happy with the person
well on the normally I would say it's
the white side of Amarok see blind
structure but this is for black but
that's exactly what Magnus is gonna try
to do right you're gonna see I would
have is Knight a5 a shot that is
potentially coming here from black sorry
I had to say that before I finished the
instructional point which is that
White's gonna Maggie's gonna try to
maneuver his pieces and get in a
position to make a strike of either
deform before because that's the kind of
thing that's liberate s-- the the pieces
behind the pawns but or not or he's
going for a different idea where he
wants to highlight the other weakness in
Amarok see blind which is potentially
this d5 outpost square
I think Bishop c4 was almost more
defensive minded though Robert to stop
threats of this move Knight a5 coming in
to gang up on the b3 pawn right I mean
95 was an interesting shot there I'm
curious just to know what the players
thought about that but the good move by
grrah shook is he's he's hoping that
white will take on on e6 the knight then
from c7 will capturing e6 and what's
more DeForest stop but if I'm white
again it's important to know when to
release the tension leave it for now
go nighty to that way he threatened the
pawn on d5 you try to go t to to d4 and
blasts open the center particularly
because the rook on d1 is staring down
at Queen on d8 it's always good for the
side with the rook and so you know from
last perspective I would have preferred
at some points have gone f7 f5 which we
have allowed black try to push for in
the center with b5 you for now I think
92 and it's the position is definitely
turning in White's favor
yeah if 92 forces a move well ok f6
isn't even possible because the bishop
is hanging but you would say 997 oh I'm
sorry yeah duh okay need to need a
little more coffee here but yeah in fact
the mate but the main drawback of f6 is
it's you know black is passive
now having to defend this extended
Center which you don't really want to be
doing the maroc sabayon and as Robert
said if white can strike with D for
usually White's pieces are a little more
ready for the open lines that are about
to happen as the pawns start getting
traded in the center so Magnus taking
his sweet time here Wow and then plays a
move on the other side of the board that
we didn't see coming
so honeybadger doesn't care about the H
pawn what a black just takes the H pawn
I was just saying Bishop g4 here right
because you know I what you can't take
the H pawn I would be very hesitant
before capturing it but my sauce okay
Bishop g4 no way I'm pinning your knight
on f3 you can't go to Knight g5 and the
whole idea from White's perspective is
to get the two bishops even at the cost
of a pawn
so if I go Bishop g4 well you're not
moving that night because Knight g5 like
captured 9 g5 then take on d1 that's a
free exchange and so this should be
formally Queen the e4 but then Queen d7
and now f5 is a huge threat this pin on
the afternoon is still quite frustrating
to deal with so from my point of view
here I think Bishop g4 just great for
black yeah I don't understand what
Magnus was thinking about h4 it feels a
little reckless for white especially
given that 92 and going for the more
traditional plan but but again Grichuk
not looking for aggressive shots doesn't
find this opportunity to go for
something different and and now we see
the reason why that H pawn is rushing up
the board it's gonna be gonna be
kamikaze here probably gonna try to just
get that pawn to h6 and do whatever you
can to open up counter play against the
black King although after h6 and black
could probably just capture on age 6 and
then try to use the g5 and I think
griffix gonna gonna do exactly that the
bishop on c4 guards g8 as it currently
stands but but I still AM I'm happy to
sacrifice in exchange bygone Queen d7
next move rook g8 you can capture me all
you want I'll take it back with the rook
now to mention that f5 no not f5 now
because the diagonals open but Bishop f5
might be a bit of annoying threat in the
near future so Nate 98 to d6 is another
perfectly reasonable idea that I think
Black has to be extremely careful about
allowing this knight Nassif
Rheda move as he just spent 95 cuz then
sacrifice on e5 could be deadly at some
moment with the bishops I'm just really
a raking on the open board but yeah it's
unclear position to be sure so Knight
takes d5 Bishop b5 for example this
could be really funny right you start to
have fantasies of the bishop and night
and everybody coming together on e5 you
know the kind of fantasies usually have
sacrifices on e5 yeah I mean but I guess
if you're from blacks perspective you
know that's an in the cards all you have
to be cognizant of that sacrifice but
don't be afraid of it be objective
Knight takes d5 Bishop takes d5 go
Bishop a5 right or is it even still
Bishop a5 now I mean you've mentioned it
before and I don't usually like
repeating the things you say but I agree
it puts the Queen on an awkward score
and I feel like black is is maybe even
they're capable of playing a move like
drop c8 because the potential
compensation on this open fire when the
lights court Bishop is gone could be
really big for black yeah absolutely I
think Bishop f5 Queen's Frey the reason
why I take on b5 and okay now go Bishop
f5 so I okay Queenie six that okay
decent move for sure I would have
preferred Bishop f5 or g8 but I guess
with sugars trying to go rotated at some
point but now worksheet always runs into
Bishop c4 so I think Bach is still doing
well because White has to prove the
composition yes that the extra pawn is a
weird double H pawn yep but this time
okay now that the Queen's come off the
board I don't think black is doing to
play Queen takes b3 I was wondering if
Queen b3 could have been a shot there
yeah by black Magnus sort of pushing all
the right buttons even if some of these
moves are not the not the best objective
moves Magnus is creating a practical
scenario where this King is now a
sitting duck to the bishop on the
diagonal these double date pawns are
nobody's favorites
suddenly I I'm trying to get this weird
creeping feeling that the positions
gonna open up and Magnus is gonna have
devastating tricks on the long diagonal
in the open e-file I'm not sure if if
Grisha could got everything he could
have out of that position right and I
still would say that black should be
better here because Europe and
importantly you're up at 2:00 well 3 on
2 from the d-day files but likely if
that pawn captured c5 then you're 2 to 1
on the Queen side and if whites attack
fizzles out and right now the attack is
only with this Bishop on b2 so I mean I
guess Knight d2 is an option here for
white 92 and 94 is an interesting one I
was looking at because you hit the
bishop everybody and then you try to
bring this Knight to e4 where where they
can gang up together I have six but Wow
Magnus is okay d5 must have the
intention of Bishop takes to play a move
like rook to d1 sacrificing another pawn
just to eliminate blacks Bishop error I
just but it does it feels a little bit
like like Magnus is really playing
overly aggressive chess here you know
trying to trying to play the big stack
trying to push push the table around
here I don't know exactly what what he's
calculating with d5 okay and I think
this is a smart decision by Grisha cuz
maybe not even a gopher tactics on the D
file simplified out because at the end
as you already said Black has this three
on on one over here on the Queen side
gotta have a big advantage in the
endgame and that C pawn is looking more
and more dangerous for black every
second oh wow yeah I was expecting this
exchange sacrifice but I think it's a
bluff I think it's sort of out of
desperation in the fact that well black
was doing quite well if you take it on
e5 of the bishop and the rook that C
pawn was running to the board very
quickly yep and now it's an exchange up
there's no check on that diagonal you
know if the bishop was gone from b3 the
bit of c4 check would be a huge threat
but now it's kind of you know I think
it's like I said it's bluffing rook III
the rook g3 is now a threat or is it can
the black King then escape king of 76
yeah right so it's kind of a lot of
hopeful chess from Max's point of view
and from rooks point of view it's well
I'm up in exchange I have this pasty
pawn and so move here like metal king of
seven I just bring the king of seven
Mitel of g4 that would have been the
trap that Magnus was looking for right
say goodbye to the rook so well that's
true I guess I was gonna take on e5
minute put my king on e6 and again my
Queens I had passed pawns or at least
from my point of view are superior to
the the things going on in the center
but it is a tricky position
and I don't think we should dismiss
White's chances completely but I think
black means black should just men should
just push for it over there on the
queenside so yeah I agree III think it's
strange we don't normally speak in these
terms right using a lot of poker
terminology Magnus sort of bluffing
maybe over playing his hand a little bit
but the position has felt very much like
Magnus was forcing dynamic dynamic
tactics and grishnak seems to have
parried all the issues up to this point
but time pressure is real and we know
that grishnack with only 16 seconds is
is gonna be nervous here I think this is
gonna be one of the things that decides
today Robert whether Grishka can make an
upset can pull the upset and win this
match it's gonna be how he handles
moments right here right now like this
moment here he's winning but now that
there goes the clock there goes the time
right I mean this is exactly the kind of
issue that I think Greg will be facing
against Magnus it's it's the Mikkel tale
thing right it's Magnus bringing the
practical pressure even though
objectively blacks should be just fine
here this looks this is looking scarier
and scarier now right you never want to
see a [ __ ] 25 with a bare black King on
G especially with the rook on the
seventh rank yep but again it kind of
appears just to be a check and so if you
know but like you said there the time
situation is really bad for Greg and
continues to be and so he made an
inaccuracy with rook takes d7 if you
take him too you said with the bishop he
would have been in a perfectly good
shape and he was still your he should be
alright but I mean that has to favor
white can say all the time and you're
right back in that critical moment we
saw that Magnus
you know his sixth sense or whatever he
played this move d7 everybody right when
Greg didn't have much time you can see
on the analysis board and that's what
got Sasha our D F six and a half seven
check is coming right yeah rookie seven
back king d8 f7 game over and and
already Magnus does what he does best
he just swindled his way to a victory
based mainly on the fact that Grisham
didn't have enough time to solve the
issues that to solve the landmine of
tricks that Magnus laid out so you know
Robert talking a little bit so a play
give give some of your advice here to
the to the fans and well how do you
handle moments like that psychologically
you know your opponent is playing
something that's unsafe
shirisha have just trusted his intuition
and just taken the palm with the bishop
and say prove it or do you have to try
to solve the tactics there too I mean we
see Magnus basically working it right
he's working his mojo against grishnack
in games where he shouldn't be winning
so how do you deal with that wasn't one
of the things to say is it's easier
sometimes to be on a losing or much
worse side of a game because when you're
better you're trying to think how do I
convert this how do I make sure that I
don't slip up and let my opponent back
in the game so for magaz point of view
his actual game plan was easy hit a
[ __ ] 25 is like hopefully I can just
push forward and start attacking the
king and then human d7 when we shook had
like 10 seconds left and all of a sudden
goes shook was kind of flustered and
didn't know how to read him so from
restricts point of view you do have to
trust yourself you'd say you know what I
am one of the strongest players in the
world obviously he is much stronger than
I am as a chess player no doubt
ronzo he won no just kidding I'm trying
to be realistic here like you have to
just trust your instincts eh
even if this isn't as good as some other
line I have to go with it with the
intuition the knowledge I am still
better in the position so Brooke just
needs to move faster also earlier in the
game it seems like he's getting decent
positions and all of a sudden spinning
really way too much time and getting
himself into really dire straits in the
clock yep well we kind of called it
right we said the this moment right
there in that critical situation with
Grichuk under time pressure despite
being winning was going to be one of the
things that decides whether Bishop can
win this match so far we're seeing why
Magnus Carlsen is up two games is is
handling those moments like Robert said
it's a little bit easier said than done
right you do have to trust yourself you
have to move quickly and you have to
push your opponent to prove it but you
you know it's it's hard for any chess
player of the highest level to make a
move that they haven't fully thought
through right so your instinct as a
chess player Robert almost gets the
better of you when you know as a
practical almost you know as a gamer as
an athlete you just have to go under
time for sure you can't solve everything
when you have no time on the clock right
right you often can't solve everything
you've if you have kind of infinite time
on the clock so right to an extent you
just have to trust yourself
frequently in chess games not just in
these
very fast boots time controls but it
just seems like either you know
hopefully Grisha can get it together
because he's just not on his a game
right now there was that moment in the
game with hit black was cream was on c2
it looked like all of a sudden that he
was the one in charge and then it just
fits onto a drug very quickly so I we
haven't seen the best of the shock yet
there's obviously still a lot of time
left in this match but Grisham really
needs to be much more precise when he
has a better position or when he's you
know in a [ __ ] neutral or complicated
position because as of yet we have not
seen the Sasha Gray shook that we've
become accustomed to and that we love
agreed the Sasha grishnak that we've
come accustomed to and that we love and
he'll be here don't worry I invited him
I invited Sasha not uncle Sasha all
right don't get too excited Robert all
right so what's going on here we have a
Rui Lopez again mainline theory again I
think this is the kind of thing we'll
see Grisham trying to do more of than
than Wesley so did but just whether it's
been mainline openings or sidelines
magnus carlsen has been up on the clock
and he is up almost a minute again in
every game so far right and in this
current position so the two [ __ ] was
two nights now in the old Russian school
classical training we love Bishop's
overnights that said this is a very
closed position look at the position of
the bischmann d3 it's just around two
pawns is not actually attacking anything
so what [ __ ] is doing is he's opening or
trying to open the Queen saw excuse me
the King sided rather and expand on that
side of the board where black has no
actual counter play some of like h4 can
come eventually h5 and from Madison's
perspective what is the plant just a
game of plans not a moves and so it's
very difficult for Magnus to actually do
anything here as Chris Chuck has very
simple play and Magnus Magnus is singing
along he's got some tunes in his head I
think he's entertaining the fans here
Magnus knows that he's on camera well I
will have to ask him about that but
Danny I mean I don't know about you but
I really like White's position here it
seems very riskless chess
and I mean I guess with your from blacks
perspective you always are going to says
night at 4:00 move right hoping that
white captures enough for to open the
e-file for that rook on e7 and - of
course remove a protector of the dark
squares and then Knight on c5 in any
endgame will dominate a light square
bishop that said if I move Knight a
forest played I don't think white is
going to take that night and maybe so
try to push for with h4 or rook g4 and
you know continue with the plan that's
been set forth so yeah it looks really
good for white and the current moment
but I don't know I think the question
becomes how to break through so why
can't continue shuffling right and go
rook to g4 after black plays but you
know blacks are trying to go a six maybe
okay night afore played first I was
saying earlier that metaphor is of
course a plan because you're hoping to
get rid of the two bishops from white
and make use of the dark squares not so
much as the pawn to e4 will become a
target but again rule g4 ignores that
night and now Queen f8 Dani I don't know
about you but at some point that y
should just capture this pawn on f4 and
say you know I'm open pawn I'll protect
my efore pawn and in the long run make
use of the fact that I'm up a little guy
I agree and I think the real issue
though is that you make this perma okay
he's going for it but the permanent
weakness on e4 and it's really also
about the dark square right in front of
it I was just gonna say as Magnus fills
it with the rook you're kind of you gave
black a little more squares there right
if you look at the position before
capturing f4 people are sort of
wrestling each other for the few open
squares now Magnus has a little bit of
life so I mean honestly I don't really
know that that was a massive improvement
for white a pawn as a pawn as a pawn as
they say the exchange rates the same
everywhere but blacks gonna play a six
at some point here Robert that Bishop is
gonna have to retreat as it just did and
here comes the other rook to e8 yeah I
kind of I kind of like the transition
for black from a practical perspective
although if white plays rook up and then
h4 h5 and I get checkmated maybe I'll
feel differently so we'll say well I
think from a practical perspective here
now all of a sudden is black with the
initiative whereas for black I
no real space the rooks were just kind
of stuck why was expanding on the Kings
side now Sutton's blacks turn this
Pawnee for is the target in the position
black can consider if me protects his
King you can consider actually
adventuring over the Queen side right
White has no protection on that side of
the board so if the Queen goes from d7
over to a 4 for example that pollen a 2
is gonna fall in short order and that
black a pawn can try to start pushing
forward that said I don't believe that
there's time to do that because of what
you suggested h4 h5 and if the Queen
ventures over to a4 well then black
might just get checkmate in the meantime
so from I think that it's kind of the
tension here is difficult to suggest
moving either side I mean h4 h5 seems
very very natural but you're always in
danger of overextending particularly
with this pawn on g5 under direct threat
so Danni I don't know I don't know who
I'd even prefer to be here I think black
just because of the long term chances
but I've you know white also has plenty
of things to be happy about the position
yeah I I guess I tend to favor the
knight and Magnus Magnus maneuvering
with that pony obviously if you could
just trade squares here and put the
knight on e5 and maybe even drop this
rook over to like a5
you'd be super thrilled as black if that
night fills the e5 square it's gonna be
a lot easier to play and I guess Magnus
is kind of just gonna play tickle here
and be in ask a square shake if he wants
to go all in for the attack and Angra
Sook's gonna do it I like that approach
because again that's the practical
prowess of black above Magnus here just
you can't do much to improve blacks
pieces already there pretty much all on
their best squares unless you could as I
said put the 95 so don't take a lot of
time move quickly let grow should run
this Age pawn and try to create some
sort of mating net and then if we reach
a critical position we'll see who has
more time to figure out the tactics
right I just feel like that's the that's
the way you have to play blitz sometimes
is like you said it's sometimes better
to have an easier plan than it is to be
better right and this rook on e5 while
it's a very strong piece and that it's
you know cemented on that squares hit 84
it actually can become vulnerable to an
eventual f2 to f4 of this rook on a
and get out of the way I mean I don't
really see it the means by which white
clothes but no that's a great idea maybe
even rook a five comes I mean as much as
I said we don't want to we don't want to
open up the e5 square for the knight but
if you could get a push like f6 at the
end of a line like that and really blow
open blacks King you may get a mating
attack so I agree with you I like that
idea for for white if you could somehow
find a way to get the full the full pawn
storm pollen storm against the King show
that King the full monty there buddy get
the full pawn storm going and there it
is Danny to be proud of yourself
suggesting the move that's been played
by Agra sugar and it makes perfect sense
right because now f4 is a big threat and
that on storm as you mentioned that's
actually very scary the weird thing
though is that this rook on g4 is kind
of stuck six oh wow man yes nice he's
willing to open up this rook as long as
he can get his a frog he's like if you
play then I get to play but I feel like
that transitions got to be good for
white right you got to just take it if
your grocery yeah he does for sure
GFG f6 and now Knight takes f6 you're
stuck with the Pawnee 5r after rook
takes e5 you take with a rook on f6 like
a rook F to g5 hoping that you capture
me on the g5 square and I can take with
the pawn even and then then I can start
pushing my F on down the board so I love
it this transition has been perfect for
grow shook and now blots in big trouble
because the extra pawn is a real extra
pawn rather than just kind of being
symbolic I mean it's awesome Boggs there
but you know it's much easier to use it
yeah and the threat of f4 is staring
staring magnets in the face not really
something that can be easily dealt with
here the last thing you really want to
do is take on g5 but here comes f4 and
blacks gonna have to take on g5 yeah
Grichuk again the smart thing to do here
bye-bye Grichuk is is to push and push
so quickly trusting the advantage not
allowing himself to get in a time
scramble where Magnus can can swindle we
saw five right yeah why not yeah I was
gonna say even even a move like Queen
III and Queen d4 and kind of sit on it
because it's black really gonna take on
d3 if I can place C takes D three I mean
no diamonds are a girl's best friend and
that's a diamond right there so uh yeah
any five
Bishop takes h7 so you're actually kind
of forcing blood to capture in d3 there
as well
oh wow that's nasty that's dirty yeah
yeah look at that everybody I got to
show the fans what you're talking about
that could be that could be real real
sticky so yeah Magnus had to take anyway
you're right and now the e pawn is
looking real strong and if it gets to e6
it's just over wait wait write a win
there's no and rook at five Issei okay
the Queen a3 plate so the lone hope for
black is that the white kings in such
bad positioning that there's some sort
of perpetual check yeah I mean the king
I don't H three right so ii six here
Queen takes a two of Queen B 2 is just a
single check the King go is that over to
h3 and now you're out of checks and so
that epon should run free rook again a
grishnak has been really consistent in
his approach throughout the day that he
doesn't want to let Magnus get counter
play but okay but what happens if Queen
B - Chuck here and then takes e5 what am
I missing
creepy - Queen f2 will be play it's okay
got it
very nice yeah forcing forcing a trade
into a lost king of pudding so Magnus
sees that takes a - and by the way by
the way whether it wouldn't have been a
king of lost key component in now
because by taking a - Magnus would
eventually have this outside past a pawn
so that's why that's why he was able to
do that yeah now the big issue for black
is that actually look at for Queen afore
you can try to go Queen a1 and pray for
a perpetual you know by just giving the
king a million checks but it doesn't
seem like it's in the cards because the
King might even be able to escape via f5
at some point so I think you have to
from blacks point of view to take on a
four and go queen a1 okay on Queen B one
first which I feel like that's not the
right way because actually the black
King on f7 is more of a target so yeah
now you can take f7 and play east six
check and you immediately get access to
the c7 pawn - I think that griffix gonna
play e6 check the moment oh wow what's
Magnus up for trying to swindle his way
to withdraw here gives check first eat
six chefs still looks pretty so what you
can't play Queen a3 check right King
upon eating doesn't win it actually
loses okay I don't know yeah actually
probably does lose both
both rook pawns of Queen up to check
King e86 I mean I wouldn't in whatever
order he's gonna play King g6 here oh I
thought he was I thought he was gonna go
all-in and try to come after the white
king whoa okay I don't know if I would
have taken on c7 but it's probably still
winning cuz the Queen can always retreat
to f4 and blockade and that pawn in game
I believe is winning because your pawns
are so advanced on the board but I would
have to actually sit calculated for a
bit but now this is unclear right you
trade Queens the a pawn starts running
right Wow what
what has Grisha calculated here you got
45 no life is just winning here yeah
Grichuk just blundered away the entire
game with Queen of three you know what
he guessed he missed king e7 right he
thought this e pawn was just wrong in
this position everybody he thought that
Magnus would have to play a four c6
takes takes a three c7 and white wins he
missed Magnus's amazing shot King to e7
and oMG Robert Magnus Carlsen strikes
again he just won another game he has no
business winning grishnack sits back in
his chair and discuss and Magnus ohm
like it almost gives an apologetic head
shake Robert are you still breathing I
am in disbelief honestly that's just how
does that keep happening go shook has an
amazing position it really is the clock
right if he hasn't how but somehow I
blame you I don't know how it keeps
happening but somehow it's your fault
I blame Fizbo so for those of you who
don't get that joke Fizbo the clever
mind okay lol moving on you know it
really is a clock situation grace shook
is not as strong with less time in the
clock we've got this I'm a time again
and it was seen in bullet portions and
in previous rounds right and so in that
situation when you know what he needed
to do itself Queen 67 so I hope Queen f2
I play a little safer and that way his
King doesn't behave king of boys all the
checks and it should have been winning I
mean I really should have quite easily
winning for a player of brochures
caliber like with such a little time on
the clock and under that duress he just
loved the game go and this game right
now
Carlson going with a weird 8 early H for
which Chris Chuck
stopped and now that the point
White has expansion over there on the
the Kings side so at some moment perhaps
you can expand by going a five and then
go H five and try to chisel away at the
blacks protected Kings side that being
said it doesn't really have a huge
benefit the moment because black can
strike in the center first the d5 and
oftentimes when your opponent expands on
the flanks you want to return the favor
in the middle of the board in the center
because that's where most the action
takes place
d5 here is just I mean from my point of
view is as black as them extremely well
out of this opening I agree shout out to
Paul Morphy who just subscribe to our
twitch channel thank you for that sir
only 27 minutes left here in the 5-2
portion and then it only gets faster
from here folks with three two blitz
right around the corner and Sasha is is
on the edge of this match really getting
away from them knowing what we already
know about the difference in between
really two players on the planet magnus
carlsen in Decorah Don Kimora and
everybody else at bullet so and then
there we have another one another
subscriber mr. Archer Knight 98 so
Robert against how do you change the
momentum here right Grisha cos has seen
the writing on the wall twice he got an
edge but took too much time trying to
play the best plan and just couldn't
force himself to get out of time
pressure and he's uh you know he's in a
position that that is almost is almost
already a must-win situation down by
three games here
yeah there's lead could be
insurmountable already which is a sad
thing to face forgo shook and he just is
spending too much time even in the
current position right he's now okay now
mags is spending some of his time but
Guk was down at least you know fifty
seconds on the clock before Magnus just
took his thing and so he has a pietà
position of so normal he's seen many
many times and again Grisham does in
classical chess as well he's a kind of a
glutton for time trouble he just really
enjoys it I don't know why I don't know
how he does funny sometimes the most
addicted to time pressure people are
some of the best blitz players we've
talked about Sasha being a you know he's
obviously a former world less champion
he's beaten Magnus Carlsen in in blitz
many times and so I think sometimes
players who who are
a bit of perfectionist and calculated
the level gristick does get themselves
under time pressure more so they've
gotten better at playing under time
pressure but no matter what you don't
want to put yourself in that position
especially against Magnus Carlsen by the
way this Kings Indian attack really
similar to the the Mishima favorite
excuse me for studying there roni and
one with it in the Grand Prix going on
at the defeat of Grand Prix in round 4
so this h4 Kings Indian attack and it's
it's sort of an old-school opening we
don't see it as often these days but we
have been seeing it more and more
recently so maybe maybe a Kings Indian
attack renaissance happening Robert yeah
and you know I fortunate for Greece
shook this d5 pawn is falling near next
move so you know the Renaissance I don't
know how great that Renaissance is for
the Russian here it's working right now
now for the Russian for the for the
Kings Indian attack players the
Renaissance is working that's true but
okay I mean it's actually not clear at
all here cuz Bishop d5 takes you put
your Brooke on d8 and that b2 is hanging
there's obviously the problem with a
[ __ ] one d5 so are we gonna see lots of
trades in the game Peter out or you know
Queen takes b2 for example now the a1
rook is under threat the policy too is
under attack you know I guess in general
you know in general terms that black
doesn't want us to be very careful
because you don't want to go palm
grabbing and loses pawn f7 is a very
important pawn especially with opposite
colored bishops but King safety is
paramount so you know Queen take c2 runs
right into Bishop takes f7 check and
that's something you have to keep in
mind because the rook on d8 is
unprotected so I think you can get away
with it but I would be very reluctant to
to allow it to happen
well he's and every I was just wondering
if he would allow and get away with it
but we're gonna see the line you were
talking about f7 Falls and now maybe the
light squares okay I didn't play I was
thinking h5 but Queen c6 has the
intention of getting the Bishop
somewhere back on this diagonal
even if black plays c3 you might see
Bishop b3 by white and you're hoping to
kind of flip the battery around and get
the Queen in front of the bishop with
eyes toward the black Kings light
squares and again it despite it being
close to equal
you've said Robert with the Alps code
bishops you look at time pressure and
you and you realize white is the only
one who can win if either side really
could win because of the potential
weaknesses on the light squares and you
just get that practical feeling that
magnus carlsen is up to his old tricks
well now white is probably going to win
because it's yes stops code bishops
White's going up a pawn but capturing on
c4 yoke and why is just better
especially because black is a weak King
losing that golden pawn of seven instead
of rook f8 which was a passive move that
I understand the attention but Bishop
did d4 there seemed just to be perfectly
logical hitting the pawn up to removing
all these back rank threats and now I
mean from from blacks point of view that
if you even do Bishop c5
I mean you yes you're attacking the pawn
on f2 but I guess maybe I'm how does
white get out of that your Bishop c5
look it looks pretty straightforward
you're right
we do check is just game over Bishop c5
queen sees three check is uh that's a
yeah that's a blunder that's nobody's
fun
maybe Christian overlooked that honestly
maybe he thought that Bishop c5 here
just held held the game for him but
after obviously it doesn't work and thus
black is now down upon finding an uphill
battle right and again in theory
probably this is still very good drawing
chances for black but you just never
want to underestimate as long as the
Queen's are still on the board and you
have an opposite colored Bishop theme on
the on in in the game everybody that
your King is always gonna be under fire
and and now Magnus is only gonna work to
continue to pry open more and more light
squares where this Bishop is essentially
a bystander to the to the murder of his
own king you know and and that's the
risk of playing these obstacles Bishop
positions where your king is the one
more exposed and this is the largest
time advantage for Magnus in the match
missed a three minute edge in the clock
but not only were shut down upon and his
king is not saved
he's down three minutes this is this is
not going well for Sasha kind of a bad
day at the office here bad day the
office so far but that the thing is we
know these guys are mentally tough and
and and Grichuk has he's boiling frankly
he's been winning two of the losses that
he had
just purely blew it under time pressure
I think sometimes the the problem is you
get in a habit of getting under time
pressure and it's hard to pull pull it
out you see yourself making the mistake
and you just can't stop yourself from
doing it but if he if he held a draw
here and finds a way to get a win or two
in these blitz portion I think his
confidence will rebound
although okay all of that is easier said
than done because as I look at this and
Edgar Shake has 40 seconds left I just
feel like we're getting closer and
closer to another win by Carlson yeah
it's so gonna play problem yep no he's
gonna deal with this because white is
you know the king is actually quite safe
even though you know they're more peace
in the border look quite open and queen
bee 2 is just one check that's that's
the biggest excuse after h6 g6 right you
can take back with the pawn on g6 but
then yeah there's eBay Bishop takes g6
followed by Queen e5 check so looks like
Magnus overlooked that tactic but okay
the bishop on c2 also will be a good
place for the battery right just yeah
yeah just relocate old-school chess
Queen and Bishop battery and you're
right I think bag I honestly think
Magnus did miss that idea but it may not
matter from a practical perspective
because grishnack remains under serious
time pressure and the only one with real
threats to worry about King h6 is
probably gonna be played and then H
takes g6 I think by Magnus followed by
Queen d7 and he's got a couple new
diagonals to have fun with h3 d7 he's
just he's almost just trying to put his
pieces on squares that increase the
chance for a blunder right from your
opponent sometimes in blitz that's what
you do I mean Dan you're right
especially here with 23 seconds on the
clock for Ashok yeah and to over 2
minutes and 40 seconds for Carlsen that
is what you have to do to win a game
like this because perhaps the engines
will find a way to defend but it with no
time the clock there's no way to defend
forever so if as long as the squeeze is
on your g4 might come at some point as
well
Queen de8 will be annoying yep a lot of
different options for Carlsen he's I
think he's using his time now so that he
could play quicker later and that way he
can just really apply the press
the clock well even though I forgot to
bring the jingle with me talk a little
bit as a teaching moment for the fans
here Robert about the psychology of a
strong player knowing they don't always
have to find the forced win they just
have to keep their opponent in a bad
position and eventually the win almost
like letting the game come to you right
to use it and overly use sports cliche
talk about what Magnus is doing here
just that that part of sometimes you
just have to sit on the position less
important that you found a concrete win
more important that you keep your
opponent down and kind of feeling
miserable about their position the
Subang Magnus goes on to win here it
makes your teaching point a really a
really good one well as district spends
ten seconds on this current move and he
might just flag because after a four he
knows new threats of word on a five the
biggest issue is that if you have a
position that is better for you you want
a position where you have like five
different good moves and your opponent
is on the back foot of the return right
instead of having a forcing position
where like you have to find every single
best move you can just shuffle around
slowly improve your position and look at
this pawn a5 and the now is on a six
which I actually didn't like I would've
kept it on me I was just about to
applaud him from getting this pawn to a
five because it prevented the scenario
of the Bishop and pawn being safely
protected but but okay Magus is still in
the driver's seat
he still is but I actually think his
chances have really decreased on that
bishops home on b6 his best shot is when
that Bishop is on a unguarded square
because the Great King sacrifices now
I'm just not really seeing the way to
there's no knockout blow that I see here
so yeah I was just about to applaud him
again for doing more of we were talking
about the pawns on a5 taking away the
natural defensive technique and you just
get this situation where black can't
hold because of all these different
threats and that's very likely how you
can win games like this even without a
concrete plan but now Magnus has made it
easier for Chris Rock as everybody is
defended Queen Bishop pawns so okay
right as we were applauding him on that
right psychological approach of being
patient letting the game come to you he
may be over pushed it on the a file but
something tells me Greg is not fully out
of the woods here though just just the
the
swindles on the lights where's our
abound
right now if I'm white at the right
moment I played g4 because go sugar
seven seconds left and contending with a
move like g4 will be a massive headache
because that you know you know leashes a
whole new set of threats between g5 and
so here I move like who goes queen
sita's gonna say just trying to get this
move g4 and so that is it it is gonna be
a big threat so right now
yeah if G's short Queen takes f4 by the
way Queen h8 and Queen h4 would have
been mates oh I wonder if Magnus should
have already played chief for but we'll
see what he goes for oh oh here here
it's Carlos yep we're hoping black found
a place in g4 Grichuk barely doesn't
lose on time they're living off the
increment if you saw that everybody went
from 0.6 seconds to 2.6 and he still
survives at 2.5 he's lost though you
know with and he's losing the position
exactly wow this is team g4 and Bishop
f5 are both really easily lights out
here Bishop Bishop f5 was a really nice
move - yeah Queen d7 was also winning so
I mean well Danny's just textbook
textbook so even despite our criticism
of of him driving the pawn all the way
to a6 it also kind of worked out for
Magnus in the end you know visualizing
this setup with the Queen on c8 there
the bishop on c2 the pawn on a6 again
it's it's just like a comfort zone
you're playing right your pieces just
feel good there there's not even a
concrete threat for white but very hard
for black to find useful moves
especially under time pressure when
there's constant tactics and sometimes I
think beginners are less experienced
players out there I've even had that in
lessons I'm sure you have - where
students go okay well I was better here
but what was my plan supposed to be and
I'm like dude you have the opposite
mindset you don't need to have a plan
just sit there and and you're winning
and kind of you know let your opponent
suffer a little bit and the blunders
will come to you right and I think
there's an over-reliance and engines
right saying oh I know I'm better here
to be right in complicated position
where I only have one path forward to
maintain my advantage
that engine tells me I'm plus 0.5 right
whereas their positions where you're
plus 0.3 and in fact send me from this
very opening that we're seeing where
white gives a slightly better position
can just play forever
and just try to nurse that advantage to
a full point so I'm
much more likely to play a position like
this where I'm seizing the long-term
edge nagging advantage that I can turn
to a full point for example here you
know you can choose between making d4
and forcing the complications or keeping
the status quo with the pawn structure
and playing Knight d2 as was just we
just see Knight f119 at e3 or g3 a lot
of players attempted to force the action
I like Chris trick strategy in this game
to kind of keep the status quo for the
time being before pushing forward at the
right moment so right know the engine
the engine generation much like
millenials right you know instant
gratification
I mean sometimes instant gratification
is very nice but another times you know
you got a you got to work you got to
work it you got to work it a little bit
yeah so let's prevent the conversation
from going any further I think here's a
critical moment as well because I'm
laughing you know the move d5 instead of
Bishop a7 but that creates a whole new
set of weaknesses on that diagonal with
the pony 5b coming directly under threat
right it's kind of a typical sort of
martial type sacrifice by going d5 but
you have to time it correctly and often
time is easier to defend a somewhat
passive position than an open position
where you have to watch out for tactics
at every turn then you know after Knight
takes e5 losing a 19-7 sacrifices with
his bishop on a two so I like White's
position for sure and I think that I can
I think white is significantly better at
this point just because hard to continue
suggesting moves for black yeah it's
tough although I think Bank is also
showing patience there and kind of along
the theme of what we're talking about
the patience of the patient approach
really being something that can pay off
and not always needing immediate
gratification or thinking that the
engine tells you something you have to
go for but but yeah I mean I agree
Grichuk is is is definitely in the
driver's seat here but you know we've
seen players this is a again a
theoretically relevant type of position
we've seen players play these positions
for both sides
a lot of this not exact this exact
position but Spanish is similar to this
variation played between Magnus Carlsen
and Sergei Kuryakin at the World
Championship so you know yes White's
better here but we'll see if you can
convert instead of an 85 was one of
Queen B 3 was possible right you're
tagging up 7 attacking before looks like
maybe I can there's no oh if I just
defend you maybe just go win upon I was
trying to and if your Queenie seven I
could have considered you the night
f-five with the tempo and ID five maybe
I don't know I'm there may I'm not
convinced in my own suggestion but I
just you always got to consider that
right the double attacks you know
hitting the pun of seven forming a
battery but here I'm here gonna say
speaking of batteries I'd love to play
Queen 84 with tempo followed by Queen a
two hitting the f7 pawn with a battery
this time the bishop leading the way but
that looks really irritating for black
now right I'm liking gross shark once
again but we've liked Richard for three
games in a row and he's got an O he's
got a donut hole to show for it so we'll
see if he can get a win here the only
reason I wouldn't like a move like Queen
a - even though I think it will be good
no matter what is that then allows
Bishop e6 Bishop e6 is not possible
because the a6 pawn has been on pre but
a deal Queen e2 then there's a pin on
that diagonal however I mean you can
always follow up Bishop e6 a Knight d5
from white and so that you know you kind
of steamrolling black in that position
of queen a2 will be a nice threat after
Bishop you have to go [ __ ] I know
something's happening here you can you
know a something wicked this way blows
because Magnus Carlsen is down a minute
and a half right this is a rare this is
a rare change of events here with with
Magnus being down on time but we'll see
if Grisha can keep that pressure and
keep moving quickly I don't beat one
right isn't that simple play the bishop
is stuck on ca protect you I love it I
mean you're taught you're preaching to
the choir here I love rook b1 I also
like Queen a2 but I think rook e1 is the
more direct approach it is the only open
file go grab that beautiful butterfly go
get it yeah I mean remember you I don't
even see how black keeps contending for
that file because well if you trade then
of course I grab the file okay okay even
he's still got rooked b1 even okay and
Magnus just concedes it and tucks his
tail between his legs moves to a8 but
again this is that another instructor
position because white is clearly better
as a nice spatial advantage of pieces on
better squares there's no clear target
right the pawn to a6 is well defended
the pawn of seven is hard to get to
since one those positions where you know
if you're let's say an eighteen
contrib player you say I know I was
better I just felt it but how do I the
way to become better it's a getting
taking these advantages and turn them
into wind so if I'm white here I guess
it are a couple things one how do I get
d4 in safely
right now the e4 pawn might be fall if I
go d4 too soon so I need to protect that
pawn on e4 can I go to h3 and just try
to expand on the King side so it over b2
and double on the B file wait all these
different options are at play and blacks
main source of counter play will
eventually because c6 and d5 right
trying to push for in the center but if
black ever goes c6 now the b6 square is
White's for the taking and that b6 core
is very important because it helps
attack the a6 pawn puts pressure on that
the newly a place pawn c6 so if I'm
right here I make a slow move may rook
to b2 and ask black you know I don't see
how I'm gonna make progress is white but
black what are you gonna do to keep your
disadvantage as small as possible so I
think it's a important moment here in
Knight h4 was played okay I mean he's
just not doing anything too drastic it
keeps them there any seven stuck because
then nigh g6 is the big threat with a
pawn of 7 pin and now Y can go g3 work
out for one f4 as well so opening up a
new idea in the position yeah the I
agree with everything you said I think I
would also lean toward being patient
with moves like rookie to not going for
d4 to fast
Grichuk bringing the Knight to f5 which
is of course another typical plant in
this structure in this Spanish game but
but if the pieces are traded and white
has nothing to show for what has been an
edge then black will get d5 as you're
saying and Liberation Liberty will come
right freedom will come to the black
pieces if white doesn't find something I
like g300 I did like g3 but now d5 comes
in if you can get away with that then
then what the heck it's actually why I
didn't like Knight h4 because the 9 f3
made d5 much more difficult with a pawn
to e5 under attack now all of a sudden
blossom Queen d6 the [ __ ] run b3 is
misplaced because the rook would love to
go to b6
so all of a sudden it looks like black
is getting out of this way it wasn't
Knight e4 moved there instead of E 4 I
would love to put my knight in the
center and hit c3
because ninety yeah I think 94 was a
decent option there but now it's getting
complicated with his transformation of
pawn structure the pawn d5 is backward
the pawn c3 is backward now the pawn a
five the Queen moves us off from a two
can be gobbled up so yeah I think you
got to go tonight yep 95 was played
black does not really want to capture
but now that now the d5 Owens gonna fall
so despite what I also felt like white
was slipping it seems like both efore d5
Falls and the only other problem that
falls clearly right away is e5 so maybe
Grisham can come out of this with an
edge still even still although time has
changed again Robert Griffin being down
on time makes you wonder about whether
he'll be able to handle the critical
moments again against Carlsen when the
swindles start to come out right but the
problem for black is do you don't have
Bishop f5 is 97 check saves the day so
after the move King g2 for example then
black has a retreat with Knight g5 and
then why control work III and try to
consolidate it's a clear and say no I
agree that's what that's what I'm
thinking is white White's getting 2 and
black only got one okay I mean on a
practical level you look at the King on
g2 you see the open long light square
diagonal you wonder about tactics for
Carlsen a move like rook b8 comes to
mind now ideas of taking on b3 so that
we can win the knight on d5 I hate this
last rookie I didn't like it I feel like
every other square was better go to d4
go to III go to be 4 for crying out loud
right b4 stops this threat of rook b8
that I'm talking about
why defenseless the rook on h4 what is
he gonna do what is he doing with the
record Annie he's trying to prevent
Bishop h3 check no checkmate coming if
you just go rook III instead you prevent
all this you know any sort of attack on
the king size or gauge for stops that
one threat but now it's such a weird
piece it's passive all it does is stop
that check and now black is gonna try to
go rook c5 hit the pawn a 5 with the
knight on d5 and so white should go see
4 here and try to regroup the pieces but
again this rook on h4 is a weirdly
placed piece
yeah I agree and you know I have to say
as much as this sounds like a general
abstract evaluation of the tempo of the
National Park but do you feel like in
several critical moments as well Grichuk
has been overly defensive and and
missing opportunities because of his
sort of almost trusting Magnus is having
more tactics or more pressure than there
really is I feel like we've had several
moments where Grichuk has played a move
like rook h4 where we're like that was
unnecessarily defensive what what are
your thoughts I completely agree I think
he has played scared chess thus far he
said plenty of good positions and in
critical moments he sees a threat
instead of just you know continuing
executing his plans he reacts solely to
Magnus threat and you cannot play chess
like that yeah I just feel you know yes
Richard has had plenty of good positions
but he also like you said has been
getting these good positions and just
reacting poorly at a very critical
moment and rookie towards I I still
think White's doing okay here not great
especially now that g1 Czech is a deadly
threat so you you might have to go
everybodyís move like c-4 would be meant
by Brooks you uncheck and Roberts ideas
that we have a fork town right after
that and look at that Queen III is
played and that already is not as good
as other options mainly because this
diagonal we kind of prophesize
foreshadowed is becoming a real issue
what if Magnus just plays Queen a8 here
and now the threat on on the knight on
d5 is coming with rook to d8 and tons of
pieces are joining in the and the pin on
that pony I'm actually just getting more
and more worried about how grishnack
handles this position as white with 22
seconds with a king on g2 of rook on g1
tactics on the light squares we're not
in Kansas anymore Dorothy will say that
by the way I have to point it there
could have been a really fun tactic
Robert let's have some fun oh wait
is 9006 trick what yeah we what was that
nice maybe she's blundered his queen oh
wow look he just rolled his eyes and
shakes his head with the Apple sorry we
were just talking about her she could
blow in the position and Magnus gives a
gift johnny appleseed makes a blunder
and I think Grichuk will finally get a
win here though he only has three
seconds two seconds
what in the world right yeah that was
bizarre I'm man's war there's threats of
Bishop to f3 check followed by rook e8
even rook e8 immediately is almost
winning what is going on here
you know in basileus a ball don't lie I
guess here scored all day ball don't lie
wait but now now they're gonna be no
black is better I back something pawns
like myself a pawn and the C pawn is
those double deth phones are useful and
the C pawn is very weak compared to
blacks a pawn blacks a pawn is nice play
a 5 here yeah a 5 a sore you could also
play King g7 just to make sure the
bishop doesn't get pinned I feel like
this has been one of the more exciting
games but it happened because of
back-to-back egregious blunders by both
players Magnus blunders a queen that was
his bizarre although in graduates
defense I mean he was he had that look
he was looking for opportunities back
there if anyone wants to go clip that
moment on Twitch we'd appreciate that
please clip some moments help us spread
the chest love make a clip there of that
crazy transition Magnus blunders are
clean and Grichuk unable to solve the
problems and is back at lost position
just like that just amazing and Greg's
made several moves like point oh one
point oh four no I know I keep waiting
for him to lose on time and so the very
least he hasn't lost on time yet I don't
think in any game despite living off the
increment in several and perhaps maybe
we'll survive this with so few pawns
remaining on the board the game is not
quite over yet well now rookie one game
is probably oh yeah there's red
everybody of rook takes e - followed by
Bishop c4 skewer town okay team v4 saves
the day temporarily kind of should be
seven no wait he still gets hit back at
least but he gave the bishop on the
right square that way
white wasn't taking the a5 pawn
immediately in fact now black is up two
pawns and should be this should be
winning should be winning you probably
even just king g6 sacrificed the look
for the C pawn and go win with two
pastors over there yeah g3 would be a
bad move here because rook b3 with
school
maybe it's a draw I don't see how that
worked before yeah oh I think Rick
should have played roof before rug
before still has a chance
why not Brooke before oh he was ruckus
e52 cut off the rook and get a queen but
King up 6 yeah you rook see probably
take take G to like it cleanly with
Chuck yeah it may still be a draw but he
gets to make that decision very quickly
no this is no this this can't be good
well he's gonna be a king before that's
the thing so I'm thinking he may win the
a pawn yeah he's getting t44 yeah but
actually this is good for black because
the Kings in a very bad spot on a three
cuz very susceptible to checks and the
King on g7 is very safe so what black
needs you to win this it just slowly
maneuver the King and pawn up the board
and you know you can okay don't go f5
here because Queen g5 check so I have
six is the better starting point and
yeah this is this is very bad to keep
trying to think qe6 now white can never
trade Queens yeah and with only 30
seconds left in the five minute portion
everybody this will be the last
five-minute game last classical 5 mini
game right after this of course we will
have some chess960 but only 25 seconds
left in the the overall game timer here
i think you know for sure this is at
this point the last game they'll be
playing in five minutes so christian
offered a draw with whoa though it looks
like there's a mate coming on b3 which
means black and force a queen trade it's
over Magus Queen check Queen e7 check is
the block response and if you chase they
say for Queen a to check followed by
Queen B 1 check picking up the Queen so
oh boy another incredible performance
going down today by Magnus Carlsen man I
mean honestly Robert you and I talked
about the fact that I mean okay just
from a pure match force matchup
perspective knowing what we know about
grishnak we thought this would be a much
closer match as compared to Magnus
Carlson's performance against Wesley so
but right now Carlson is just gonna mean
kin skin can the man be stopped
I mean this this is maybe go down as one
of the best months ever right I mean his
his performances and these rapid and
blitz events this month have just been
out of this world
yeah he's proving why he's the best
player in the planet but nobody I mean I
bet you even he didn't expect that he
would dominate such strong Clair's
convincingly as he has and I believe
this is okay this is the eighth game in
a five-minute time control that has to
be one of the shortest is not the
shortest match in speeches championship
history which is the opposite of what we
had between Carlson and so on on
Saturday right we had a I think we ended
up having a 13 game five-minute portion
so tale of a tale of two time management
sessions but it doesn't matter it seems
to be the same results for Carlson
either way with it with a huge lead
right now right and if we get into the
position that we have on the board
we started off here as 960 so it's quite
random but for now that looks kind of
like what has an English structure right
yeah yeah
Muncie for Bishop on this long diagonal
well both bishops on the long diagonal
right now and actually what I don't like
about blacks setup the bish 1d8 find it
difficult to get over to f6 or g7
especially this knight on d5 because you
know look at the bishop on a1 staring
down the Queen on h8 not exactly a good
strategy for the Queen yes exactly a
happy neighbor like the kind of neighbor
that stares you down and you know
they're about to smile the other
neighbor that stares you down is judging
you the whole time that's what's going
on here well now after Bishop f6 you can
be muted just take it gnashing that that
piece up there disappear oh no well that
it's actually I think he's gonna play
Knight g3 and then rekar oka dropped the
King on g1 and he's gonna fix the only
remaining dysfunctional aspect of white
setup which is that the king and rook
are kind of awkward maybe yeah time to
get castled and leave the d3 scorer
behind because here comes black yeah
though castling you know you do have to
be we're gonna ventral h5 move right
just trying to blast open that side of
the board so you know I'll take my
chances with if I Castle they play ch5
I'll play g5 right sounds like I can get
the F station where or
whoa whoa kingi to Magnus using the
chess960 set up says I'm not even gonna
not even get a castle so I wanted to go
eat for but you can just capture on e4
so it doesn't actually do anything
yep but you always to keep an eye on
that move with with all the tension on
that long diagonal so how do you improve
your position as black here I guess you
you know you can you two might just be
the best move I made the other bet
honestly looks fantastic that's the
truth and now black excuse me white
consider going b4 and then b5 and take
you know just expanding on the I really
still like the threat of g5 coming and
even if I'm not I mean what idea of g5
and then b4 Robert is that that frees up
the e4 square so that White's other
night can get involved in the f6 party
but even if I don't get that idea I mean
g5 and I put the knight on f6 I can win
the dark square bishop it just it feels
like white has very good long-term
attacking chances here right and the
reason reason I was hesitant to play g5
initially from from whites point of view
says thing Oh h6
you must be forced to trade Queens but
the quencher it actually helps white
there's 25 h4 and white is clearly first
to that age file so black needs to
consider what do about this King can't
Castle queenside and really you sorry
you are able to Castle queenside but it
is a bad move because then before be 597
checked will be a quite painful so yeah
not looking pretty for black and as we
yeah they'd almost sound like you're
about to bust out rap along with Carlsen
and Eminem right after this well we were
talking about rap before the before we
went out live so you got some up in my
head no but look how long King a to make
Grichuk think before okay what about b4
b5 now doesn't bring that bring the pain
on the B spot it looks pretty natural to
me I think if they're before you're
forced to sacrifice a pawn to e4 because
otherwise B 496 b5 I love it I love it
it's also there's 97 oh yeah I think
that's why e4 was played because there
was 97 check coming perhaps and uh yeah
b5 first right just kick that night out
get get that check in just
disastrous but now just Knight takes e4
it's a free pawn yep yeah if the if the
knight had if the knight had moved
everybody before he for there's there's
threats of b5 in the 97 check picking up
the bishop over here on a8 so that was
kind of Robert's point of the b-pawn
push and Wow
Magnus is giving the light square bishop
with check no less but I guess if black
takes it white takes back and after the
trade Magnus will take on c5 at the end
and then maybe pop a pony into f6 a nice
little outpost square yeah and then you
can also just consider on Ruby one Ruby
three we've got the other book to be one
and try and do that that's a nice move
there
bye-bye crush check though rook e8 I
think you have to just leave the tension
don't even bother taking the C pawn and
Magnus is gonna try to simplify the
position so take stakes we guess rook
yep rookie 694 checked f3 is coming yeah
absent I concur six pieces coming to
life here
Magnus should gobble h7 probably they'll
just go go get it get a pawn maybe I
think magnets try to oversimplify is
like well my position is so strong and
it is right it's leave you look at it
optically speaking White's position is
amazing however there's newer tactics I
play with 94 check opening that Bishop
on a 8 Knight f3 calm seeing the rook on
G 1 and both pawn the D 2 and H 2 so
actually shook is it's kind of changing
the dynamics his position in his favor
could take him out cheat day take on
each other we might lose the knight 94
check tonight f3 then rook over to h8
you're 9 NH 7 is trapped oh I didn't see
that the night comes Fe with tempo
everybody hitting the rook and now
taking away the g5 square makes this
move rook 88 a devastating threat I like
that line partner yeah I agree this is
getting this is getting a tasty here to
be funny if grishnak wins one position
where he was completely worse as black
and chess960 rather than the three games
where he was clearly better in the
regular classical portion but you got to
take him where you can get him at this
point if you're Sasha crook
gotta get a win although the pawn
structure would get really weird cuz 94
Chet okay I didn't go to 94,000 go 94
you tasty I should just play f3 here F 3
d3 do something to defend the night so
that
your h7 sorry so your f6 night is free
again yeah I like d3 maybe even f3 was
fine but yeah taking on c5 was very
questionable it should've gone Knight d4
check and again I say this every time a
new commentary it's one of those
positions where quality of pieces is
more important the quantity of pawns
because I've been down upon temporarily
but all of whites pawns aren't weird
squares and your rook was not state
active on the e4 square if all those
trades occurred so now I mean okay black
still hanging in there because rook a6
will be annoying at the right moment and
not to mention that you can consider
capturing on e4
but yeah I agree but again I mean I
would classify not taking the
opportunity to play 1694 cuz 94 King D 3
Knight of 3 with tempo then there would
have been threats of 95 check again
followed by just the threats against
these two knights who are trying to
guard each other and again puts us in a
position to feel like with aggressive
opportunities on the board
Grichuk is being much more defensive
minded than he is being aggressive and
magnus is taking advantage of that I
mean on a practical level Magnus is
pushing and and creating weird dynamic
tactics even if they're not a hundred
percent sound for him yeah there's
speaking of not 100 percent sound yeah
this moves 90 there's no way Grichuk
isn't just better after rook takes d7
he's gonna get two pieces for the rook
yeah rook d7 19:56 I wonder if he missed
after Knight takes D 7 was rook be to
check first because if you don't get
that check in first and ok white will go
rogue b1 and try to trade rooks and I
mean white will have a rook and two
pawns for two minor pieces but with the
threat of rook B to check forcing the
King as a back rang then the two pieces
are just gonna bring on the full points
oh and so here's a moment again where
Grichuk is taking 40 seconds what to
play the less than ideal approach here I
feel like there's almost a giving Magnus
too much credit this is what happens I
guess when you when you win a blitz
matches by 20 games you kind of
intimidate your peers maybe it just
doesn't feel like Russia cos calculating
all these lines as accurately as we as
we know he normally does but I didn't
understand it at all because I
understand oh now now why cos rook b1
and everybody's gonna grab the only open
file and have very good chances here
with the rook and a bunch of pawns
well my essential question is in what
universe is the rook on d8 better than
the rook on d6 right even if you did
initially that rook is swing to a6 this
rhythm dude's doing nothing well I mean
this idea had to be to just get an
active King right we know you want a
more active King and end games but I
agree with you that you know the more
these pawns get the center there's no
way this King can compete with those
pawns and those squares anyway and
whites just I mean there's threats here
of rook c5 there's threats here of rook
v1 there's threats here of c5 check and
then King III and just push another pawn
and get a massive massive center storm
going so I mean all in all now between
rook g7 rook g5 c5 check King III yeah
and then play d4 and d5 or something I
mean white just feels in total control
here ya know this is uh this is not
going well food we shook it all I just
wanna give a shout out to what a noobs
in the twitch @s judging restricts moves
here we get rekt 30 0 by crusher respect
people who call me out for calling
others out I don't know I don't know
what players expect but isn't it isn't
it your job our job to do commentary but
of course I mean a blender is a blender
of regardless of who plays it everybody
that's a fact
anyway yeah I know it seems that seems
that Carlsen is is really gonna show us
how to Brooks would output how it rook
would outplay minors this is the kind of
position everybody to offer some
instructional takeaways you have open
files on both sides of the board ok so
that's that's like a warning sign you
can add to that little database of
knowledge when will rooks be better than
minors you have you have numerous open
files you have numerous pawn weaknesses
h v e6 e7 a7 and finally you have the
potential to create your own passed
pawns that the types of positions where
Brooks will do well is is obviously it's
it's it's self-explanatory files where
they can swing from one side of the
board or the other when there's pawns to
target the minor pieces would rather
have all the pawns in one little
grouping upon island if you will so they
can maneuver and work together this
situation is just one where the rooks
are kind of made to outplay the miners
and Robert would what do you say is that
a fair that a fair description although
now
like magnets just plundered no maximum
blunder he purposely was giving up well
I didn't like the move I don't know if I
love what just happened there but I
don't think he blundered he
intentionally went for a line where he'd
give the rope for the night because he
felt that he couldn't make easy progress
and said okay my pawns are gonna push
forward and win the game but now I think
black is better because pawns aren't
that quick and in fact if just I'm
highlighting how the rooks could be
better than the miners Magnus makes a
sacrifice of the piece and so uh well he
may he may live to regret that I think
the rooks were doing very well there
yeah now in fact it's only one pawn for
the piece and you know they're very pass
pawns but you can't actually go f7 with
this a5 pawn maybe you can't because
you've rushed the e pawn and Queen would
check f7 takes takes everything a
through e6 a to e7 chatter d7 checkmate
now Oh sweetie
in the middle of the board Ingrid wins a
game fix a funny face you gotta look
Magnus for bringing the entertainment
there Robert
and completely completely overlooked it
he completely overlooked it and there's
absolutely no denying it on his face
that was pretty funny as he gets up and
takes a break so will we and do a quick
summary of what we've seen so far even
with that game Magnus takes a 6-2 lead
into the 3-2 portion Robert Hess you're
in the corner so Qing Sascha grishnack
out of this hole what do you say well
you just gotta stick to your guns he's
had many good positions as far but he
needs to play more quickly especially as
the time but she'll get shorter three
minutes to start the game with the
increment you know he just has to trust
himself more and stop giving too much
respect to Magnus Carlsen well we we've
seen almost everything here we've seen a
one move mate right Carlsen just
self-made it and please clip that moment
again if you're a fan in the chat which
TV slash has somebody create a funny
caption to go with the clip and we'll
share it via our chest comm Twitter
account let us now that was pretty
hilarious especially given Magnus's
reaction but Robert speaking of
reactions what's your reaction that you
can now sign up for Garry Kasparov
scores at masterclass
our sponsor we love the support for the
speech Chess Championship have you seen
the new trailers and some of the little
teasers are putting out about Kasparov
saying game and did you know that rook
ending trap that he teaches okay summon
the rook in game where you over before
yeah yeah oh that one no I didn't know
it I pretty feel pretty confident would
have figured it out but it is really
cool seeing the legend Geragos part of
teaching everyone how to improve their
chess
the your coach remember on sheer didn't
teach you that Philly probably but some
of it is that you forgot well either way
let's take a quick peek into the class
remember you can go to master class calm
slash chess right now and sign up just
calm members can get the full course
even though it's not available to
everyone yet if you sign up it is
available to you let's take a peek I'm
trying to come up with the comprehensive
picture that will be helpful for you to
become a better chess player and even a
better decision later check I want to
show you the ultimate deflection the
ultimate sacrifice so here we are white
pawns see their advanced a7 b6 c6
the ship is pinned all working white
favor but there's one problem
it's check if white King goes on a six
then geometry works in black they work
we need to check and it will be a
perpetual white King will not escape do
you see any way to prevent black Queen
from attacking our King and forcing draw
has it work
Queen g5 and that's one of the lessons
of the Sunday
magnus carlsen given out a few lessons
of his own though he just got he just
got what does that post your eyes what's
the basketball thing where you get
someone someone dunks in your face is
that posterized that is absolutely being
a poster but if we but if you self-made
that's like stepping in front of Michael
Jordan before he dunks it right is there
a self post posterization yeah I think
it's one of the moments where you step
in front of LeBron James and that'd be
more accurate because that is just you
know just the you're just asking for it
right in front of Michael Jordan I might
get fancy I'm front of LeBron he's just
slamming one down right in your face
well we will see how Magnus recovers
here as grishnack is is still not at his
seat we wait yet a few more moments
Magnus already back there and ready to
rock probably wants to shake off that
that checkmate on d7 for those of you
who maybe somehow just joined us let's
back up real quick and show you again
Magnus plays f7 and mates himself with
Bishop d7 good old-fashioned family
front fun the PG kind and we're about to
see more of that right now as the three
minute portion kicks off Robert Hess
your call what do we got here well let's
say we got a little 8:45 action we're
gonna restrict must have loved the
position he got from that previous game
where he had the white pieces and I well
not just me Danny we both loved his
position and we got a Berlin but we saw
this in was the computer match Danny the
Rio de Janeiro variation or that night
heads to be seven yeah and it looks like
both sides know what they're doing I
used to play this as black the point is
that black has the two bishops instead
of trading Queens again your King stuck
in the center blacks in a castle at the
right moment attempt to play f6 you know
the problem with plenty f6 often is that
right now for example f6 there could
have been to be six move because the
policy six is undefended so it makes
blacks like very difficult and so black
here should play move like Bishop to c5
or work to e8 and then slowly maneuver
out of this weird night on b7 situation
and you know it's it's odd right Daniel
is are you
Berlin games in your day but I think
this one makes it you know the man me
the Berlin hanging out recite your your
favorite city in the world my favorite
city in the world favorite boring
opening to fall asleep to in the world I
just turn on turn on commentary V plays
of the Vladimir Kramnik Garry Kasparov
2000 World Championship match to go to
sleep at night well you were just
mending Garrick Apsaras master class you
can't take away his like what's the
opposite of a master knows that would
that would that yeah that was the
opposite of a master class garry
kasparov not being able to bust the
Berlin against ramnik in 2000 because
it's an unbustable opening not he didn't
he didn't not try it wasn't due to a
lack of lack of trying
but yeah you and I just saw this opening
in the chest calm computer Chess
Championship last week right yes this
was this night of b7 did does does black
know that Knights don't move diagonally
in this position I mean this is not an
ideal position for a pony it's not but
right now Bishop takes d4 Queen takes
for d5 making use of the fact that pawn
to e5 is pinned to the rook on you wants
a no i'm poisson possible and from
whites perspective
typically when you face this pawn shops
you want to go Knight a four go before
and just try to make sure that those
double pawns of CFR are not making any
progress can I just say that really it
really gets me hot when you guess four
moves in a row it really gets me going
really gets my juices flowing you just
guess so many moves in a row I'm shaking
over here in my office well you know I
was gonna make a point about actually
how the name b7 is a good piece here
because it keeps the c5 scored defended
and so you know what normally white
wants to go B for control that Square he
doesn't really do anything because the
knight on b7 is covering c5 and I mean
why does c5 under control himself but
here rookie six swing that rook over to
g6 go Queen h4 in the near future to hit
the knight on a force a rookie six here
and all of a sudden whoa Magnus wants
more what's going on with the c6 pawn
FYI
Wow Queen d7 a positional sacrifice if
you trade on d7 everybody now you're
gonna have to play the move b3 and black
is just better in this endgame despite
being down upon because of White's
horrible pawn structure
look at that little trick that was uh
that's that's actually really awesome
that was a Magnus specialty right there
can I get one of the Magnus specials now
the c2 pawn is under fire I mean what's
interesting is it's still hard to say
that black is better here I mean he's
down a pawn in an opposite colored
bishop themed position but but with the
pieces jumping to life this e5 pawn is
weak the c2 pawn is under fire as we've
said you kind of start liking black here
yes but I think that's each upon Falls
because then there's a past D pawn that
is defended by a bishop on c2 so here
rub d8 right yeah you got to play rook
88 ok c5 also I guess ooh
nice move Queen t5 threatens Bishop
takes d4 everybody because the pawn is
pinned something tells me we're gonna
have a sassy little three-minute portion
I'm telling you right now we're gonna
have we're gonna have some sassiness and
not only is Bishop b4 through Bishop
take c2 you can even consider going east
six right that's all yeah definitely
should get she got out of that he
grabbed them he took the money and ran
Billy Joel I love yous called sassy this
is gonna be a sassy
well something that the cool kids say I
think my my twelve-year-old son says
sassy but then again he may not be cool
I don't know you know as soon as you
think your kids are okay well he thinks
he's cool that's for sure but no
seriously though grishnack seems to have
gotten away with the like a thief in the
night for now but still you like blacks
activity the bishop on a5 hitting c2 the
Brooks the rooks are also better on dat
8 so Magnus plays tickled with in these
positions so well just plays h6 and says
ok no now your turn white Ryan II in
some ways mags is waiting for restrictor
plate f4 and we've talked to us in in
some of the earlier games once you make
a move like f4 your King side actually
becomes a much weaker then of the rook
can go to e6 and over to g6 and may
apply some pressure on the Kings side
and that's why h3 I like that move
because there's no rush to play F for
your pawn t5 was defended for now if I'm
black I gets their Bishop c8 to go to a6
or the b7 yeah I love Bishop c8 also to
come to b7 yeah you did say that just to
get the the potential battery over here
we know opposite code Bishop positions
can lead to really dangerous attacks if
you can if you can get it going right so
the two out McQueen be sick is also a
good move swing over the g6 we attack h3
and c2 it's one of those nice double
attack the main reason I think you don't
want to move the Queen from a5 is you
got that you're nicely poking on e one
right Robert if the rook ever moves from
a1 it's possible the a to pawn could
fall so Magnus as much as he wants to
sit and just hold water as well it's
hard to see an exact way to improve his
pieces that don't also give up something
right right and shout out your last
subscriber there thank you so much for
your support thanks to everybody for
tuning in and pretty sure we've had
record numbers today Robert of all the
speeches championship matches so far
pretty sure we've had live viewer record
numbers I know you're really into that
you track obviously I was gonna think
that carvers Magnus last year probably
was the oh no no no I meant this year I
meant not this year but yeah Magna
Magnus in a car last year is this game
is headed wrong
well weights up a clear pawn now yes
opposite colored bishops make it
difficult to make too much use of the
pawn but now rook c5 right hitting that
a ponder shake is unwinding he did win
the last chess960 game everybody a
little bit of momentum potentially
swinging back the Russians way thanks to
KL and Q who just subscribe to our
channel and I think both side just
overlooked a nice little trick yeah yeah
v rook takes a five and if rook c2 then
rook F 4 hits the bishop on a 5 and
allows that Bishop b2 to escape the d4
square so I think that was a great
winning chance for a shook there and now
after a3 which looks more or less force
the game should be good Peter very cross
although no you're right that was thanks
Danny right east 6 is always something
to keep in mind
you got to play that out you got a place
he'll know the shot yeah everybody
Robert had in mind was just to open up
the seventh ring potentially to try to
do what you have to do to really have an
edge in obstacle Bishop positions which
is really get the initiative because
small amounts of material that concrete
aspect is often not enough to win when
your opponent can just set up a blockade
on the opposite color square and your
ship is helpless so so even just from a
practical perspective I would have liked
to have seen one side tried to be
aggressive and look for an attack using
their color Bishop right and so bishops
you know okay I was a Bishop c5 into e7
and to f6 is one idea to try to keep
black completely stuck
so now g h5 okay i'm in place v here
yeah but then i take on an f5 necessary
a king will just sit on h7 he's gonna do
it though and I think he has delusions
of grandeur just like Danny going for a
checkmate on the dark squares yeah but
he would that the bishop doesn't have an
open diagonal to work with so he'll play
Bishop d2 I think he's they're almost
trying to lose you know he's almost
trying to who's just like Danny would
yeah I didn't say it was a good idea I
just suggested it Robert
remember that non there's no chance that
white losses came but it's clearly a
draw at this point yeah well Magnus
needs to try to trade rooks and he does
so just to make sure there was no rook
down to be a tour or try to get the rook
over on the dark squares so but okay
awkward each other like three draws they
just keep missing it okay yeah they're
just like ships in the night kind of
like our relationship these days Robert
I you you call me species their ships in
the night all right well we're back to
this little nimzo-indian dealio four
really ill we're gonna get an i QP some
that make stock fish per out
yep stock which was loving that in our
computer Chess Championship and the
point is again this black pawn on d5 is
not always easy to defend now earlier we
saw a six Bishop takes e6b takes he
takes an e4 and that was actually a game
that got out of it and even had a better
position here he takes a different route
and goes with the bishop on e6 keeping
d5 exceptionally well defended and now a
white takes on C save got their B takes
c6 you have the two bishops four black
you're in white isn't quick enough
to a knight a for whoopsie one and apply
real pressure on that side of the board
so if I'm white here I should retreat
the bishop does I say to d3 rather than
take on c6 and that's actually what
Magnus just did once again Robert guess
in the moves and the ladies go wild okay
Bishop c4 h3 but the the main thing
though is that even if white had to make
this for treating move you still I mean
blacks counter play and what you
normally need to justify this week pawn
on the open file and isolated pawn has
no long-term positional protection
because it's isolated right I mean black
needs more pressure than he's getting
here I still kind of like White's
position given that normally you see
black with a little more of an
initiative to justify the permanent
weakness right and engines tend to like
think these positions are about equal
because they think trading off pieces
well and I mean they they have no fears
their engines but I think tray of the
pieces makes black leaves black in an
all right position sorry that I'm
faulting my speech here but ya know I
know you're saying it but the truth is
on a human perspective at least if the
minors come off it just gets white
easier to a position where he can play
for two results maybe he's not winning
like you're saying but when you have an
isolated pawn in an endgame with no
counter play your opponent is in the is
in the driver's seat and they can just
gang up on that pollen until you break
and here I mean black has ideas I've got
Bishop c7 or to b8 and on Queen onto
that diagonal and that's what White has
to be really careful though because
white sure is aiming down in the d5 pawn
note that you can't capture on d5 here
because after Knight 65 Knights he said
Queen takes you out there's always
Bishop H to check it's a important to
keep that in mind always for some of our
newer chess players no you're right in
and I like and the black is now trying
to get the kind of counter play we said
we you know we want black to get be able
to justify the isolated pawn I actually
like this move Bishop e5 maybe he'll get
D for now and simplify the weakness
that's a very common idea if you have an
isolated pawn to look for an opportunity
to trade it because normally if you've
done if you played your cards right with
an isolated pawn you should have more
active minor pieces because you had you
had more open files and more open lines
due to just the natural aspects of the
structure
your palm was isolated so with it came
some open avenues and and if black can
get D for normally normally is okay
although here you're probably white
maintains a little bit of an edge if
they just trade it off everything into
the endgame because this Bishop on f3 is
immediately targeting b7 and these
double pawns but I still like d4 from
Greg and I and I think this I think the
black is is equalizing now it was
interesting they took with a knight
because he could have taken with a queen
on d4 and then traded Queens and just
left the knight on c6 which kind of
blunts that Bishop one f3 however I
really like the decision here as you
were kind of just hinting at because if
Bishop takes b7 and rook k7 the rook can
come over to 2 to d7 everyone p8 rights
and a nice little battery there that's
what's gonna happen me up he flips the
script on the D file and and now you
just you feel like black should have
some tactics here where is it where's
the discovery on the lady Knight I don't
see one quite yet but it should be now
Bishop da da I mean you always a
considered Bishop be a right to go
Christie's to get the Queen and battery
going yeah just to do that but you can
also I mean I guess the other thing is
what's White's running okay white is may
be threatening nice c5 in some positions
you don't want white did fork the rook
and the pawn and kind of simplify but I
was gonna say maybe white doesn't have
any useful move so maybe you could sit
on the position a little bit and and you
really like the knight in the center you
love the rook on the D file but here's
the problem Grichuk is going into the
think tank and now we have a minute a
full minute time advantage for Carlson
Ryan's again one of those moments
Bishop e8 was sort of the obvious move
right you of course you know you're
thinking about playing that eventually
so why spend however many he said almost
was that forty seconds I'm Bishop you
hate I guess who's trying to work on
discovery and Knight move but no but
you're right again and again it's easy
for us to say and you and I have already
been poked fun at by the chat who are we
to criticize grishnack and Carlson
believe me everybody s and I don't have
any sort of thought or ego that we would
be competing with them in this format
but again like it doesn't mean that you
know you're what you're assessing here
as far as you can sometimes see the
writing on the wall even better than the
players do when they're kind of locked
in the emotions in the end the X's and
O's of the game it again Grichuk is
taking too much
time on moves that Robert and I had to
be fair we suggested it like three
seconds after the position was on the
board right and so again those sort of
things when you it doesn't seem to
matter but then if you lose this game
because of time pressure one of the
things that show you know what I'm
realizing Robert we haven't talked about
yet it just shows that Magnus just
played a match on Saturday and maybe
Grichuk is a little bit out of form cuz
I think you can you can agree with the
fact that one sign that a player is not
quite in their best form is taking 30
seconds on a move they could have played
in five taking two minutes on a move
they could have played in 30 seconds
right that those little things add up
when a player is not in their best form
that's this is just true and right now
we're struck has found these ideas
Bishop a7 rook to e2 this petition is
actually quite easy to play for block
you're down upon yeah you're the one
with all the threats on f2 is gonna be
quickly become a target
look at how passive White's not on a4 is
it we don't like our Knights on the edge
of the board and so from critics
perspective he's on everything right
except for keep his time above Magnus's
so with the extra four seconds in the
position now sorry almost 30 seconds
asthmatics in just to think if that's
the only thing Madison's going for him
right now the extra pawn which is not
real because I can even just take on be
chewing over b2 yep and then tape it
probably just rook d2 oh I was gonna say
maybe gristick should play both d2 first
be a little more a little more more
stubborn on that tray but he still is
the one as you said a little better here
the pressure on f2 is real and nothing
else in the position really is right
yeah because white is very much stuck
here the rook can't move from f1 cuz I
have two Falls and the knight actually
doesn't have anywhere to go to protect
f2 because 93 just hangs the pawn on b3
with the tempo and so all of a sudden
black is gonna be the one who is gonna
go up a pawn it will see right and what
we've been talking about is these the
practical aspect of time pressure you
see Grichuk really kind of arched and
sitting up I think he knows that this is
something he he doesn't want to have
happen again again under time pressure
and so I see some comments in the chat
making it being made now about our
comments about the griffix time
management one of the one of the best
comments ever about that is the book
towel but from the book Talbot Vinick an
autobiography about their match by
Mykelti I'll hear his thoughts on kind
of time management practical stuff it's
a lot about what we're talking about
here
all right Grisha Quinn snap
and he is better again and look at
Magnus's time but but but it will he get
another win he need he needs to keep the
momentum going his direction
you know I'm looking at the time is
actually getting quite even and so Luke
c3 interesting move idea beyond 96 rooks
e6 and that's a much easier endgame to
play for black where you're up upon with
the outside past a pawn so yeah he's
gonna get it
viagra shook who's now up about five
seconds wait going for a trick rook d6
doesn't work as of Knight FA check
everybody so Magnus is forcing the rook
ending but after I was gonna say even
rook f6 is almost interesting there if
you can get the King out this is this is
better for Meg for for Grichuk then than
some end games he could have got but
maybe not the most winning chances
possible but yeah but don't
underestimate that these n games are
winning here's what can happen the
Brooke can come to f5 okay Magnus being
very smart not to allow that because one
of the things there is if the rook gets
itself in a position where the King is
cut off from doing what Magnus is trying
to do now get it active then then these
rook endings are winning for black that
the black king will eventually get over
to the a file and help the a pawn
advance but I think Magnus has
simplified enough that this should just
be a draw right then the reason why is
because the rook on eight the white rook
is behind the pawn which is essential in
defending an endgame like this black
wouldn't love switch places to wear the
white rooks on a three in the black
works in a seven push the pawn up and
then try to move over the king over the
Queen side now unfortunately for Ashok
with his rook in front of the poly make
it difficult to push too far and this
move f6 I was gonna say at some point
just give up this pawn the King goes in
that v into g6 and you're gonna have to
get at least one pawn and the game will
end in a draw so yep now white will rush
thinking back and it will be a draw as
soon as the King touches down on c3
there's no way to check with the rook
and free the pawn without King to b2 and
Bob's your uncle
okay well I guess from griffix
perspective you haven't lost the last
couple games right I mean and after
winning the last game in
five-minute portion though it was
chess960 the momentum feels much closer
to equal now than it did where Magnus
was up six six to one at one point yeah
I mean it's definitely closer but at
some point you've just score points
right you can't just say oh I'm feeling
better
I feel like an even match with him okay
when you're even matched drawing every
game we're down four that's not gonna
help so unfortunately for Gersh cook he
really needs to play catch-up in the
Hestia to it right now yep okay we have
another another Lopez I think this exact
line we saw in the World Championship
between Carioca and Carlsen several
times yeah and and actually shook he
didn't get this quite position earlier
but the sort of same dynamism in the
position where it's a slow methodical
maneuvering game and so I like the
decision by Chris shook because he has
been able to accumulate good positions
and so 1972 the knight on a5 has to move
in exactly why co c4 quickly and so
white expands and this reminds me
although it's not quite the same of the
game recently between karyakin and and
Spindler where Kuryakin got a c4 move in
but they were lifes were fish on the
board so it was different but the point
still holds that white is expanding
quickly and trying to get a nice spacial
advantage and ask black what is your
plan I agree and and I wonder if there's
anything to that we have a grishnak the
Russian obviously a team native circuit
cardiac on
playing openings that cardiac end is
also employing regularly both as white
when he played Carlsen at the World
Championship and as you said recently
versus fiddler so I wouldn't I wouldn't
be surprised that there's something to
that I think that Grichuk has shown he's
trying to challenge Magnus and some
mainline theoretical positions these
grew Lopez's are not positions that
they're only playing in blitz openings
right these are these are serious
openings where white feels like he can
push for an edge a small edge and
outmaneuver his opponent so this is a
much more theoretically relevant blitz
match I guess you would say than the one
we saw on Saturday where are lots of
sidelines right in here already black
has a bit of a difficult decision
because oftentimes when a pawn on b5
isn't you know pawn right in front of it
and there's a
an a four-point tagging a five he's an
idea for black hoping that if black
white Busby takes a five black goes be
for quickly and then takes back on a
five and tries to make use of this
isolated pawn on the a file however if
you go to a five here then Y can take on
B five eight sixty five eight six before
and B takes c6 with a tempo and the
Queen such that White's pawns are all
connected and black has this isolated
beep on that is a passed pawn for the
moment but if targeted can quickly fall
so a5 is not recommended from black and
instead it was d5 sacrificing a pawn in
a different manner hoping that if white
captures a bunch of d5 black will go
from d8 and scoop that pawn right back
up also b4 is hanging I shouldn't
mention yeah I over first so this defy
break looks timely then yeah it's
interesting timely and maybe also a
necessity though right necessity breeds
timeliness or genius I forget one of
those things but I I really like that
that point you highlight about why a4
was such a strong move from from grukk
and of course taking the pawn would have
never really been an option everybody as
this transition greatly favors white and
so Grichuk needs to handle the tactics
well but he should get a small edge
probably at the end of some sort of
forcing line here given the black was
kind of forced to play d5 aggressively
but the truth is but before falling it's
hard to imagine a position where
everybody is not just coming off the
board right White's gonna trade blacks
gonna trade takes and takes and takes
and everyone just takes and we're gonna
get a draw because black will eventually
Reese coupe up those pawns on the D file
right and so the only thing that black
really has to be concerned about is if
somehow after Queen takes d5 we trade
the Queen's and the bishop takes before
if the bishop in one turn go Bishop d6
to c7 that would be very problematic for
black because then d6 is it's cemented
and black has no way of actually
attacking the pawn on d6 because the
rule can go to d8 so instead of taking
on before Magnus first plays rook to d8
and this should be well okay if I take
on b5 so HH b-58 takes b5
rook a7 Bishop takes b4 there's no way
at least not knowing that I'm seeing to
protect this pawn on d5 well you give
nobody that's a good line
rook a7 Bishop takes before Brooke b1
with tempo and then Brooke takes me five
and I think that that would be a line
that white could could maintain the edge
so I really like your line a takes b-58
takes rook a7 pose the difficult
question to the bishop gain a tempo okay
Grichuk finds another approach he likes
though I'm not sure that ours wasn't
better shout out real quick to justice
bought Bona bonds Ani several title
players playing guests to move in the
chest comm arena their chests calm /live
or just click on one of the buttons
below chess TV and you'll follow the
games instantly so fun to see so many
players playing guests to move
especially title players I wonder if
it's a good way to get better right
studying chess rights try to sit there
and actually guess how Magnus Carlsen
plays in real time probably can't hurt
right how's master I'm asking for a
friend Robert we all know I stopped
trying to get better years ago asking
for a friend about how to get better at
chess yeah I mean it definitely should
be helpful because you're watching the
best players and that's how you and
generally you get better you look at top
level games and here in this particular
game this is let's see okay so Bishop c5
let's take what the part of the rook
it's the essential question I have okay
we trade with the rook and and the point
is after Brooks e8s not actually
threatening to take this pawn because a
back rank checkmate everybody so now I
think or she can play rock a5 okay if I
I guess it's just gonna be a big equal
trade b4 yep rugby five and then just
make love for your King and why can you
get there in time you if white could get
the King to stop the b-pawn in time you
would see white maintain serious winning
chances but next move everybody yep we
get the trade of this pawns and once
again now we're an endgame we're maybe
maybe only Magnus could win but given
that it's a rook ending I would just
offer a gras a draw if I'm grishnak and
try to get as many blitz games in as I
can and but if you're Magnus you might
start playing match strategy and just
prolonged this as much as possible well
I think I think brick is playing match
strategy or either that or he
listening to me and he offered a draw
but I don't know I think of all the
players I feel like Magnus's best Matt
strategy is just to be Magnus and he
doesn't think like that he's like I'm
just gonna play every game the same
thing I would do overall and and win
although he he did he did display some
mass strategy versus Nakamura in the
final last year weren't there weren't
there a couple games where Magnus just
kind of drew it out and didn't let
Nakamura make a comeback and bullet does
we commentated on some of those games
right yes
no he definitely he you know Magnus
knows what he's doing for sure and he
speaking of knowing what he's doing he
once again goes for this variation in
the Sicilian so he's not testing with
Shooks who is extremely strong Sicilian
player in main lines but kind of going
for slow or offbeat more solid lines and
without risking any huge theoretical
discussion so the point here is that
white eventually will try to go a 5 so
in black just like a 5 himself and once
again if we see the move d5 come in
which I was gonna hope they wish to
avoid as he just did that black was d5
and the e5 pawn becomes a target the
bishop on g2 becomes open instead the
bishop on g2 is still staring down into
its own pawn essentially on e4 black can
continue to go b6 rook c8 Queen d7 and I
think black is doing quite solidly here
so nothing to be too concerned about at
the moment but strategically speaking
black has to be very careful before
making a move like f7 f5 it's one that
you always to keep in mind but you also
really have to be concerned because are
you opening up that Bishop on g2 so for
the time being black is probably gonna
be preparing it moves like h6 are
suggestive of the fact that black wants
to guard the g5 Square from the night
and and because he may be preparing for
a kind of a spatial of salt here but I
really like Magnus is last couple moves
I just had to say because C for giving
this night on on b1 a new a new plan and
the night comes in to d5 I feel like I
feel like this is this is now I want to
say it easy or edge but it's a it's a
flexible position for white it's easy
for a white to play this position on
both sides of the board
it's a Botvinnik English structure
actually a symmetrical
bought Vinick English which again not
something you see every day and not a
fan of this a takes b5 stuff I mean my
Grichuk yeah when I get this position
from the black side and opening up that
rook to attack the pawn is never a good
idea in my opinion because that yeah on
eight Ria's well defended the bishop
just sits on c1 but at the same time I
guess the knight become a c6 and then
the Queen can you get I guess I don't
know how you double in the a file
because it's always nice c7 threat so if
you're black you have to consider taking
on d5 at some moment well I think maybe
blacks idea is to play his knight to c6
Knight East seven to c6 and then and as
he does so then maybe look to take on d5
so that he can pop his pony into d4
we'll be getting a structure where maybe
if it becomes ooh but in exchange did
Magnus miss Knight a7 he definitely
missed nice and wide me take out first
and d5 I think that was better if you
tell them d5 first and then took on b5
Oh although he's still gonna be able to
do it but I agree Grisha could have
everybody once Magnus missed that he
trapped his own rook Richard could have
taken and then played 987 a little bit
easier to play without the extra white
minor piece here but I think I think
Magnus making another blunder here again
okay this is not a huge ok White's not
resigning here right but but black is
definitely better there's no way Magnus
was sacrificing that exchange I wasn't
looking at his facial expressions I know
rare but I wasn't so I did I didn't see
his reaction to trapping his own rook
and now white has to do something like
Knight d2 to c4 so you know structurally
it looks kind of nice for white because
you often like having his a and B pawn
versus his backward beat b6 pawn you put
in an item c4 throw an a4 a5 and that
seems to be in White's favor however
given the current situation where black
sub-material it might be just not enough
to provide anything close to full
compensation though again 90 to 94 is
very natural
I says earlier look at that clock white
is up a minute on the clock it's a much
easier plan at any moment black has to
consider how do i consolidate my
position to get a full point because it
desperately needs to win this game and
scheme I would look at that I think
that's I think that's the right
practical approach making sure
that we don't get exactly the kind of
position you were just talking about
Robert where this night comes to d2 and
sinks itself on c4 and whites in
complete control especially if the
position remains closed the the rooks
can't flex their muscles
I think c4 is a great move by Griffin I
would agree except for the fact that d6
pawn is now under attack but though I
guess you can consider me he's gonna
take on before now because I don't see
it how you getting advantage otherwise
an important thing to see yours I've a
nice c5 d4 is a bad move by white it
looks like you're getting rid of your
double pawns but after each safety for
Knight 284 Bishop takes for Queen takes
e4 it's an amazing night on c5 versus a
bishop on g2 that doesn't really have a
great future so something to keep in
mind is that d4 you know you might have
to play it at some point obviously Dani
but it gives the end well not the end
game that will you'll see in the future
it's just very good for black I agree
and it does make anything for a second
okay maybe I overreacted to how much I
like that thematic kind of positional
sack of c4 a few moves ago but I still
think black is the only one who can win
here given White has so many weak pawns
d 5b v b3 I can't even highlight him
faster than the players are moving okay
but man if this Knight comes to c4 again
Magnus just in a very practical fashion
not carrying about all of his material
he knows he'd rather give up the d3 pawn
in order to get this Knight to c4 and
get the pressure it can exert and that
that kind of attitude may be what saves
White's game here why it's gonna make
sure that he gets his knight and just as
good of a position as black knights here
comes Knight c4 yeah I like I like
Magnus is defensive idea yeah here I
think black has to try rook a to because
otherwise now that one the d6 of b6
pawns will fall so rook a to threatens
efore bye-bye bishop d4 idea so root k 2
as play but maybe what exactly yeah
moving faster than I can walk all in
here they go he takes b6 and Magnus has
intentions on the B spot I'm pretty sure
that was a rap song but there's actually
a big attack going so I'm like white
moves the knight then Bishop d4 yeah
really
even without the Queen's on the board
once again how many opposite colored
bishop themed attacking ideas have we
had today
a lot right and actually if that f2 pod
falls then black may be able to
sacrifice the bishop for the b-pawn
because the e3 that eventually pawns
hard to stop with a knight on d3 so this
is actually based going for it in Greek
has fully sat up again as grishnack does
well arching his back and and really
kind of kind of being on the edge of his
seat knowing he doesn't want to get it
or time pressure but a little bit too
late for that with only 20 seconds wow
this is and this is a very very
complicated position right now yeah look
at that
threats of night f2 check now followed
by a bunch of checks in a draw maybe
Grisha gets to bail out yeah I would I'm
gonna I'm gonna I think it just has to
bail out Knight g4 check probably yeah
just you know the king can never run
anywhere kf1 always runs into rook up to
check and loses so just this is a nice
little a surprisingly peaceful result to
a to a really sharpen an exciting game
but no King no King denies himself a
little pickle tickle we move on with a
draw I don't know how to respond to that
so I'm gonna just look at the chessboard
because that was I don't know what
you're thinking about it's just a game
that they play it reminds me of Morty
episode so anyway back to the chest so
we see another King's pawn game where
we've come quite acquaintance with these
lines as you mentioned Danny a lot of
these kind of closed structures are very
popular in the World Championship match
between Carlsen in Korea but again I
think it said some good Russian prep
here I think that Grisha cariocans
fiddler I mean this is uh this is a line
that Grichuk is is believing he can play
comfortably
he knows the plans intuitively he can
play the lines quick I mean so this is
like mainline stuff he's gonna try to
get an edge against Magnus and if
nothing else people who actually still
care about getting better in the Marie
Lopez might actually learn something
from these games and with a little post
review because I'm not convinced Magnus
as it doesn't take 15 seconds there to
play Bishop d7 for a reason
he's trying to think you know he's
really trying to assess and play a
position that he knows is theoretically
you know sort of sort of relevant right
and speaking of actually it's not
relevant at all but everyone on Twitch
is going crazy about my pickle Rick
reference from Rick and Morty so did you
just win yourself some twitch love I
think I did oh man you know I feel about
twitch love the last chat says thanks
has for ruining chat now I'll go back to
doing what I'm good at or hope that I'm
good at is talking about chess games and
here this is theme Matic from carlson is
the C 5 e 5 set up you're trying to
challenge white in the center on d4
square by the same look at that Bishop
on f8 so white ideal situation is
trading off both bishops and night for
the light square bishop and both the
blacks Knights getting night versus dark
square bishop is always favorable for
white flashes they always but often a
favorable for white because the bishop
on f8 is very passive and this is a look
at the bishop on c2 it's kind of just a
piece that's sort of stuck for the time
being that said why can any mode can
consider going d5 or a4 is it's just
played and so you're competing both in
the center and on the Queen side
particularly because the rook just left
the a file over to c8 that's why black
doesn't want to allow the opening of
metal ions I don't know Danny I feel
like these positions always require
really a ton of maneuvering and I feel
like I need Anatoly Karpov and right
right
Favre is a master class but I feel like
I need Karpov to whisper in my new here
because either that would probably be a
more useful co-host than me as I'm
offering him very I mean okay no we can
talk strategy here and apply some good
takeaways but you're you're doing all
that all by your lonesome so I don't
need to add much I think this move d5 is
interesting because it also kind of puts
the kibosh to Black's intentions with
the rook on the C file the disadvantage
when you push the D pawn robberies
you're always making as you highlighted
the bishop on c2 even more of a big pond
behind your chain but you prevented
black from you know a transition
sometimes black looks for everybody is
white does something else and black
takes on c3 takes on d4 and just blow
open lines and opportunities on the
queenside so okay now now Grichuk is
gone a maneuvering route where he's
gonna try to take advantage of these
potentially weak B and C pawns because
they're they're sort of extending too
far and now the knight comes to c4 and
d6 is a target I actually really like
this entire transition for grishnack and
once again I mean I don't know what the
results gonna be once again I mean this
has been a very successful Spanish from
Grichuk about it's theoretically you
know you eat you're about as happy as
you can be with white in this position
with an awesome past a pawn and and
positionally better in the center on the
light squares right and if you're white
here first thing you love that a pawn
right that's a passed pawn and you asked
black where is your compensation gonna
come from at some point black would love
the crew zombie eight for example to go
rook takes c4 and then b3 but that's
just you know that's just hope this
hopeful chest it's folly folly sorry
that's right I said I've always wanted
to use that word folly and you know I
walk in I think Girish it's just gonna
chop on f4 - yeah look at Magnus is all
in on your idea partly because you know
blacks position was either sit there and
let myself be grinded ground a great
grain did a gray what's the okay
nevermind yes the ground to health but I
think I think Richard goes on to get a
win here I think this is this is exactly
the kind of Spanish game that Grichuk
knows so well and look at the time time
goes with it to prove a grishnack is
actually up on the clock yeah and look
at this [ __ ] bum b3 you know it it's
looks like a big poem but it just
defends everything yep now like a five a
six if he so chooses
'if I've is is definitely something to
keep an eye on and so you know what is
black do here if you move them you know
weird the route many eight going it
doesn't have a good square to move to
because it's work aid everything is
defended okay Bishop c8 when I guess
it's going over to a sick for naughty
five ride just blast out but especially
when you're up the exchange shout out to
our arc Archangel Condor for subscribing
thank you for that whenever you have the
rooks obviously you want to open up new
lines and opportunities that's how the
rook out plays the minor that's what you
do when you're up the exchange and look
at that Goering plays e5 I don't know
why I'm getting so excited about this
but something's tingling inside me
and I need to I need to let it out I
don't I wish I knew
oh I don't know it's where to go with
that Queen b6 I guess overlooked because
Bishop e6 is more natural pin but Bishop
d6 runs in a real tasty a check so Queen
b6 has have been annoying but rook AE
one then maybe 97 and what's going on
there hey what no I think I think white
is fine rook a you 197 I mean I can I
can sack my I can sack my lady can't I I
don't know I'm concerned about that
because then the past pawns are kind of
annoying on b4 and c3 but rook a 197
maybe Knight f5 is also possible there
just take your radishes a little man
well Grichuk obviously agrees with you
that there's something to think about
here because the tables have turned and
suddenly that tingling feeling I had
inside has gone away everybody gets
nervous their first time trying to
convert here
alright well he's gonna go for this line
but yeah I mean look at how quickly
Magnus is playing and yeah Magnus is
like well I'm not gonna miss my chance
but grishnak finds that f5 that was the
way to save white's edge right there
because now if Queen b8 you could take
on on EI Robert and then 97 check does
that help ah I was seeing just a knight
takes h6 check Knight takes a 6 check
and then give me a check on the G file
and then take your broke on e8 so the
prince is I think forced by black oh
yeah now we're good that Queen Queen
somewhere Queenie 4 right that way you
pin the night lots of pins why not just
push the pawn if I guess you're worried
about Bishop c5 coming from black and
surprisingly Magnus is actually still on
out of it if he can grip the dark
squares white lacks white lacks the dark
square Bishop to challenge that that's a
really critical point that's why
grizzard plays d6 you got to stop Bishop
c5 now there's 297 check coming maybe so
Bishop f5 Queen f5 yes then c5 is always
in the cards
so here when 93 but Knight oh it wasn't
nice ACH 6-pack is winning Oh 90 x h6
checking the Queen g3 I didn't see that
that would have been a factor d
a little double attack desync is falling
with check now or not now I'm very
confused
maybe Queen d5 and then you can push c5
next just you know don't get too excited
what g5 g5 and the night is running out
of squares but you could have taken on
h6 I mean yeah but now black has more
than enough for the Queen right but why
should taking on e6 and on Queen f6
they're threatening Queen da check
throwing the pawn on g5 and the bishop
on aged six that was the last hope but
again no time for Chris trait to
calculate all this I mean you know it's
the time that's coming back to bite him
and and he may he may go on to lose this
game I'm shocked and again it has
nothing to do with the opening or a
really I think sound the match strategy
approach from Grichuk he is getting an
edge against Magnus Carlsen in the Lopez
but he just can't convert under time
pressure oh oh man oh man this is sad to
see to see to hear Ryan he's gonna Queen
you know that's a lady that's that's a
new lady that pawn had dreams to one day
grow up and dance on the stage with the
other divas I just you know I wonder if
there was a good analysis of a
percentage of time that aside was better
if quicker sugars actually been better
for more of this match than Carlson has
because and maybe I'm just is a recency
bias of him just winning game being in
winning positions in Blount like you
know kind blundering it away but I don't
feels to me like Chris sugar did so many
good positions just can't hold them
through I agree and that would be like a
time with it's almost you're asking for
like a football step like a time a time
of possession stat right like and no it
isn't interesting cuz often when you see
games where a player or team really
dominates they dominate all the stats
and time of possession is a big one
having an edge on the board and chess is
about as comparable to time of
possession as anything and I would agree
that Grichuk has had an advantage for
the majority of his moves even if it's a
slight one and then big blunders under
time pressure has has basically been the
story of this match
I like that you know that's a stat we
should add that's a stat we should try
to track as it's time on the clock and
it's something we could only do in the
speech Chess Championship Robert because
of this of this overall game clock right
we can actually track the match time
yeah you're pretty interesting I just I
don't know it just keeps seeming to me
like Chris shook his head and then all
of a sudden not but in this current game
let's see what's going on here I think
mmm it's complicated because you know if
white is gonna catch this pawn to c4
they try to go up a pawn you to watch
out for this long diagonal the bish 1 g7
is already broke on the D file but yeah
ya know for sure and so it's already a
big threats just go make a move like
Knight to g4 Knight to d7 90 d7 will be
very strong actually for him be 64 97
Bishop before a5 and already black is
winning a piece so yeah I like yeah I
wonder what Magnus calculated there cuz
clearly now he's trying to think his way
out of the position lots of tactics on
the diagonal that c3 Knight is a problem
but even here 97 is still interesting
for black I guess maybe better just to
develop they should be six Bishop a6 huh
yeah black like I said okay but again it
this hasn't been the problem right we've
had 97 actually is tempting as well so
97 Bishop d4 it's kind of thematic and
after Bishop before you can even capture
and go 95 and just try to take over the
D file the c4 pawn Falls and he does go
97 I like it this is very similar to to
a line in the King's Indian the same as
Hughes Indian wear black sacrifices a
pawn for sort of long-term compensation
on the dark squares and and here black
is down this efore pawn but white white
needs coordination in the worst way and
black is likely gonna win back his pawn
before white gets it well actually is a
huge threats are on the board so maybe
white might I don't know if I would play
this but I'd consider playing a movie
Knight d5 just sacrificing the pony and
trying to
kind of record innate the pawns but
looking not good for the 945 that's an
interesting idea
from a practical perspective and there
it is 95 I feel like you know Philly's
madness finds those moves just more than
anybody right the the the thread is
slipping right and he finds the way to
keep some sort of threat on the position
to make them make a practical imbalance
that makes you have to reel in the game
not to say black isn't better here again
but we've seen this dog-and-pony dance
before grishnack is better here he's up
a piece for two pawns but but now it's a
whole new psychology and in the in the
previous position Robert you're you're
grinding down and you're trying to work
your way into the dark squares you're
looking at all these ways to kind of
have long-term compensation for the pawn
you sacrificed now you're in a position
where you're better but you have to deal
with the onslaught of pawns and find
optimal minor peace coordination before
it's too late I just feel like that
those little things are things that add
up in the bigger picture of the match
and make Grichuk nail spend some time on
the clock he's no longer gonna be up on
time and you know rinse and repeat
prevent your receding hairline which
I've been meaning to talk to you about
appreciate that thanks but I waited pawn
on side they just say a pawn slot like
you had the opportunity right there in
front of you not yeah by gosh you're
right I missed an opportunity to make up
a word I didn't have a game well
speaking of not bringing the a-game well
we've seen who should go down the
scoreboard but you're right Danny I mean
he's it was a good practical decision
and not just because I recommended it
for Carlsen to go 95 but how do you
convert a position like this you know
from my perspective over here it's
annoying really annoying that I can't
actually chisel away of these efile and
defy pawns all right because I can't
really go to f6 any time and the pawn on
d5 is very well defended by the bishop
on g2 so if I'm black I need to figure
out the best way and I guess at some
point I can go Bishop f8 and bring this
bishop to the other diagonal just to
kind of avoid the pawn structure
altogether but I don't know I'm not
seeing a clear path forward
but I like that move maybe you don't
chisel away maybe you bring a jackhammer
baby whoo but that I don't be fun I
don't know
all right night mb5 night on f5 maybe
maybe I mean he did just take advantage
of a very timely pin and that night on
c4 had had served his purpose so I think
you play night b5 anyway here and then
you look you look to be aggressive with
your rook
okay now Grichuk is where she is you
know what if anybody should have some
good old Russian schoolboy technique
it's grishnak so he needs to put on
those big boy soviet pants and go to
work here he needs to get some technique
on and win up a piece of this hanging
for the kids for the boys yeah no
definitely for the I mean the problem is
again is that this rook is now
struggling to find this activation that
was what's what's necessary to actually
win this games you get the full point is
game the rook activated in a way that
doesn't actually allow white to activate
the rook first rookie three and all
about that Wow rook c1 checkroom d1 Jake
Weiss tasks as difficult as possible you
don't want to trade rooks here
I guess you trading rooks probably makes
White's hold easier I guess so you want
to keep your book on the board to create
counter chances against the King no I
don't like I don't like Russia critic
doesn't agree
he likes trading but but again I feel
like in some of those moments critic is
making decisions based on time pressure
and defensive mindedness against Magnus
although you know SIL is very clearly
better for black but again without the
rooks on the boy I don't say you're
gonna make any progress you came to
attacking in the pawns a shout out to
our sub there I'm not gonna read your
username aloud because I was tricked
several times on Saturday into reading
no unfairly friendly used her name's
Robert I don't know if he got that and I
didn't realize what I was reading nope
didn't catch it at all so I did I avoid
it right there you're welcome I know I
don't want to hurt your virgin ears I I
was going to say something now you just
like this conversation is better left
for off
stream alright anyway back to chess
things that you know g-force coming if
you know yeah and he pulled uh he pulled
a Rio de Janeiro and fee and cattle his
night but now he's me working his way
out of it yeah the more pawns that are
traded you mean just a certain point
there's nothing left so black somehow
needs but I just don't even see a way to
win this game black needs to get this
night magically over like h2 yeah when
the G there's nothing I can't even think
anything conceivable to happen the black
and win this game
yeah plus pollens are running out right
every pawn that's traded is less
opportunity for for winning an engine
where you're only up one minor piece and
make it so much so now that grishnack is
just gonna throw in the towel I mean
there you go there's a move
come get it big boy come get it he's
gonna undermine the e5 pawn everybody
takes shake and bake and the d6 pawn
Falls well if you an f5 Bishop e5 Bishop
takes g5 I mean the ideas that take the
knight on b8 and take on f7 maybe I can
play f6 yeah then I go Bishop f4 I guess
yeah but that's this is the best way to
play for a win is just to try to
maneuver around and no good ships doing
his best to make it interesting but I
just don't think there's enough left
here you got to find a way to win the d6
pawn before your F pawn gets traded if
you do so you have a long-term chance of
winning winning like a knight and Bishop
checkmate kind of endgame which wouldn't
that be some highlight Abel clippable
material let's hope we get that friends
and family on twitch TV and chest comm
TV more and more difficult for white
because Bishop d1 check already is you
know gonna put white an uncomfortable
position tell jib good old-fashioned
family fun good old-fashioned Russian
schoolboy technique that's what
grishnack is gonna show here and get up
get a big w as black this should be one
not check ok but this also worked he's
gonna win that d6 pawn before the F pawn
falls that's the key okay I thought he
was going to he's not going to
was tricking you I'm gonna move zero
time on the clock here comes g5 and that
should be enough actually for Magnus to
draw okay yup or doodle scoodle draw
town draw town and the reason this is it
draws because the king can just stated
itself on h2 and the bishop would just
remove on a diagonal and there's no way
to actually deliver a checkmate because
you can deliver a check without trading
the bishop so last time we checked you
can't mate with a solo King and Bishop
adventure Oh Robert Robert Robert only
seven minutes left in the three-minute
portion the Russian is running out of
time to make his move
and apparently Magnus is running out of
time for something that has nothing to
do with this with this match here maybe
he has to go attend to some services
yeah you know I'm a little disappointing
you because you started getting
inappropriate when you said you're
welcome me earlier did I know this one
I just watched Moana the other day focus
forth and you know see where the rocks
things you're welcome yeah yeah yeah I
was gonna like do a play on that but you
just got really inappropriate to wait so
quickly for me to deal with I'm sorry
I'm sorry so let's reset and arveleï
what what did you want to say just it's
over dueling is it too late yeah you
know that guy at a party who liked the
moment has left five minutes ago and he
just continues to try to bring it back
because that's his moment is to tell a
joke and and it process ends up just
kind of outing himself as a total weirdo
yeah I just didn't know if you knew that
guy that was all all right well Magnus
is back he's got his headphones back on
all is right in the world we've got a
Berlin come on give us a mainline none
of this Rio de Janeiro that's what I'm
talking about the mainline Berlin
alright that's what I've wanted this
whole time I feel like you're joking cuz
I don't think you ever want to see in
Berlin again this is this is where it's
at Queens off the board before move ten
very little opportunity
for an advantage for either side
somebody's somebody's really getting
heated over here heated up man all right
but jokes aside right after this
everybody don't go anywhere of course we
will have the bullet portion there's a
good chance robber we're looking at the
last three minute game right here and
grit being down five games knowing what
we already know about bullet this is
getting tough and again magnus carlsen
like he's he's just good right he's just
good it's hard that's the most I fulfill
your promise ed I mean thank you I think
thank you yeah he's just good and it's
and it's it's it's really hard to play
chess against him is that also
insightful it's really hard to play
chess against Magnus well I mean just
you know quite honestly he's very he's
such a strong intuition and that longer
controls it still matters a great deal
because you know they're spending more
time and they have more time to think
but there's so many different branches
so many variations and it comes in
useful when you can conserve your time
and still find the best moves
however in three minutes and one minute
chess you know if you're able to just
find things at the speed of light or you
know I don't know I'm not a scientist I
shouldn't use that expression I was
gonna call you out on that but I thought
you might have stated a holiday and or
something so it's let you get away with
it yeah if you're able to find things so
quickly then it saves you the time and
you know you're essentially avoiding
situation like Rashad gets into ingre
structures but II 6 which is somatic in
many Berlin's because it opens up this
bishop on b2 and now oon f6
yeah this is also a thematic response
right because you try to take advantage
of the overextended pawn by making it a
target rather than taking the bait and
immediately capturing it that might fall
something like Knight to b5 kind of a
double attack on c7 and g7 right and now
Knight h4 is an idea for white trying to
use those light squares the g6 where the
f5 square and what black needs to do is
a free zone ith for Knight Bishop takes
six maybe there's some Knight b5 stuff
going on yeah so you know it's a it's an
interesting pawn sacrifice just to get
the initiative and already it's becoming
very difficult for blacks from 96 afford
yeah no this is this is a like you said
it's a thematic idea this East six
sacrifice is not something that was just
pulled out of the the wind here it's
very typical and both when the bishop is
on the b2 let's say Chi seven or eight
188 diagonal and when the bishop is on
the h2 C seven diagonal right Roberts so
if you're a you're a Berlin player for
either side take note of this idea
because it's very often kind of a key
way for white to turn the tables on
black and really get some pressure like
whites getting here although I achieve I
love I'm seeing the full pressure hasn't
that any six can't move for the time
being because rookies haven't checked
but I mean night at four year isn't the
men of five just hanging yeah I don't
know Robert I was trying to talk about
the idea not the specific tactics
well United me like that the problem is
I was gonna agree with you but then I
realized that was a bad idea so right
and I said well okay Danny must be
missing something and so just your pure
principle of disagreeing with me brought
you to your senses so in a way you're
welcome okay it's okay I'm just an
ordinary Demi guy here all right so what
who are you watching my wanna win I get
tortured to watch that with my daughter
I mean I don't know where your ads that
of is that a voluntary thing there it
just happened just let it be but no okay
some white sacrifice upon hoping for an
initiative but no honestly it's just
winning I think that I think that
Grichuk is he's throwing his hand up and
kind of just frustration with his
calculation there cuz you're right is
even though it doesn't change anything
we said about a six being a thematic
idea to open the bishop on either
diagonal this was just this was just a
wonderful game and I think they have one
more game now to play in three minute
because of that and I'm not sure why
they haven't started their next game yet
neither mine but what I was gonna say
though is that you know the problem is
Rookie seven is just one check and we
know that can't you just move out of the
way and then your attack is over
and so with hanging pieces of course the
nine-to-five in that position
just not not doing the trick so yeah all
right we have another Sicilian oh and
this time we don't have the the kind of
slow methodical you know French
variation Sicilian and maybe we'll get
some kind of mainline tamaño going on
right so this is gonna give us some
extra match time today I mean this is
one of those rare times where this game
is starting and it's gonna end very
quickly as far as that total game clock
we see there's only 42 seconds left so
this game will probably go on for
several minutes past the hour sort of
extras will call it stoppage time and
and then we'll get another chess960 game
before we move into bullets so still
lots of chess to be played I'm having a
blast we also should give mags a little
more credit for that last win because
didn't he like go to the bathroom at the
beginning I mean I don't know what did
he do whatever he did I told you he was
attending to some services often it's
either a snack or some food services and
I wasn't sure if he's going you know in
the temple or synagogue or whatever you
know whatever to each his own whatever
services you need yeah as long as
they're not no Danny don't say that
don't say that something about something
about chess here do we have a note my
client just said something that I can
also can't read on air which is we have
officially reached the end of the 3:2
portion and we have our first truly
mainline Sicilian which should actually
be focused on this here because you
described the fact that Magnus has been
avoiding the kid that Sicilian with his
Kings Indian attack but if we back this
thing up on the analysis board everybody
we've got a mainline time on of Sicilian
this is all theory and after Bishop D
for Bishop e7 Queen f3 this is I okay
I'm not an expert in this particular
line of the time on if I actually play
more of an English attack style time on
off with a move like Queen d2 and
castles long back on move seven Roberts
so what do you know about this
particular time Manav as far as the
theoretical relevance and and what both
sides are playing for here right well
you see
why just one Queen g3 and I was gonna
say what also is always in the air is
some kind of queen to the H files of
Queen h3 or h4 trying to open up the
Bhishma on d3 so unlike some other
positions where this Bishu and d3 can be
attacked by a black knight those Knights
have been traded off right early and
thus those bishops sit pretty in the
centre that said you know black is
actually quite solid and has a couple of
things to consider g6 is always a
consideration you know Knight @ h5 just
kind of poking at the Queen a little bit
and saying even more even the the Nigel
short 98 right and just tried to bring
the bishop to f6 to just simplify the
pressure on the dark squares right right
and so here g6 probably does not come
recommend it so it returns back to f6
immediately and now there's the Queen h3
exactly what I was talking we need three
has an interesting thread everybody
black has to watch out for the immediate
moves like Bishop takes f6 and then e
five with a discovery on the h7 pawn so
that idea Robert highlighted there also
Knight d5 friends I mean same idea kind
of is clear that diagonal for the bishop
and trying to get at this Knight f6 so
h6 here or g6 are the two moves that are
gonna have to play g6 I'm always nervous
about but could just be all right
because then black note e 5 and once you
go E 5 you're in the reason why you're
nervous is because the d5 square is the
one that you're trying to keep under
control but that said by going h6 you
also have to keep in mind that at some
point white might consider a sacrifice
you know Bishop III takes h6 it's
certainly not out of the question
at the right moment and so instead
Knight yi8 was playing and now Knight d5
it's probably just great I love Knight
d5 who do I love it the e5 now maybe I
mean let me just grab the bishop pair
even and run home well things a 5 right
you have to a g6 I think I'm I can now
put a pony into f6 yeah why not
well g6 I might just take on e7 Queen e7
and take on d6 and use my bishop on d4
against the exposed dark squares so
there's nothing wrong with expose
your own darks words as long as it was
voluntary but you may regret it here Oh
Danny Danny honestly don't know what
you're laughing about half the time but
I do appreciate it
you just you know user funny guy but
night take see 7:27 eat six d6 and you
can't sink back with a rook on d6
because then Bishop c5 wins in exchange
you take back on d6 with the night well
then the you know you queen h6 is
tempting you can just go Bishop back to
c3 it's a moment the mission could be
for yeah this is not pretty for a black
yeah this isn't scary time on of attack
here this is something is gone something
is not right here for white for black I
think I like the simplest approach best
the one you described with Knight take
c7 and gobbling the d6 pawn and even if
I have to play a move like c3 just to
hold that Bishop on d4 I've got the dark
squares even without any concrete frets
plus we may have some real fun puzzle
book mate of like rookie 5 and then sack
the Queen on h7 and rook age 5 and mate
on h8 but okay I digress in my fantasies
of possible checkmates whoa peace sack
alert what oh he's gonna take on EA this
is getting closer and closer to some
sort of tactics trainer like finish if
he takes d4 Robert he's gonna play rook
e7 first I think inner mizo push the
Queen back to c8 and then maybe
something like big sorry go ahead
no you're right and actually in this
just a second ago black could have gone
taking on f6 because now Bishop e3 if
you take on f6 is Bishop g5 try pinning
Batman f6 to the roof NDA so Bishop e3
here keeps everything under control and
white is just much better yeah but I
still wonder if Magnus didn't doesn't
get the best or the easiest position to
play this way cuz the f6 pawn is also a
target whereas the variation we were
sort of considering for white just to
take e7 and open up d6 felt like such an
easy position for white to play given
the mutual time pressure that always
occurs but okay Magnus Magnus wants the
whole thing apparently to
game and he's willing to get under time
pressure himself this is one of those
rare moments where Magnus is actually as
low as Grichuk on the clock yeah I think
we're sure Katherine ie4 here oh I don't
like 95 the problem is that in an open
position that bishops are much stronger
than knights and you also have a
two-on-one majority in the Queen side
blacks King side pawn majority they're
not going to get moving any time soon
especially this bishop on c4 pinning the
95 so yeah it's looking real nice for
white here it's probably all the bishops
double the fun and yeah this is this is
just such a tough position to be black
especially again with not very much time
on the clock Bishop before words a very
smart move with the idea of going c5
with Jack so yep and also if the King
stays on that fate you're just
threatening to play a four now because
there wouldn't be any Knight shakes
before due to the double attack so now
our key seven it should be five I take
on you can take on a six
I gave me just trade bishops on d5 I
wanted to jump on kind of well Bishop e3
yeah I was gonna say we should be three
rookie one Czech king of to rook up one
shot King g3 rook F no wait I forgot
what was covered by the bishop
Touche you got an F Plus on that one you
barely passed you know I was gonna throw
a water boy reference there isn't call
myself Bobby Touche Bobby Touche lol
come on Dan that's about as corny as you
get buddy right there Bobby Touche
that's why you should have said it
that's right one of them specializes in
Corning here yep I say Bishop d7 not
only is a pin the 95 loves that movie
a4 a5 a6 is uh and they'll come along
goes marching on do you want to be in
the number that's right born in I was
born in that number and Magnus Carlsen
is putting up some big numbers okay I
mean I don't even know what to say right
now Robert but another win in the books
chess960 classical chess
you're back on camera due to some
requests in the chat I think chess bay
and some others were really looking for
that face of Robert hassle Robert oh
tell the people what they're seeing here
the greatness of one of the I think
Magnus Carlsen beats anybody in history
in this format I mean he is just the
rapid and blitz
it's like he's better than he is over
the board I swear it
I mean his his numbers don't the numbers
on live and it's probably right because
he's been so quick in every single mass
he said I mean it has what's a close
smash has been a part of I don't even
know what did he beat hit Carl by in the
finals last year the grizzly match the
Grichuk much matched last year was you
and I were on the edge of our seat it
was the opposite tale of what we're
seeing here I mean Grichuk was leading
the majority of the time and I think
they entered bullet within a 1 or 2 game
you know standing and then Magnus ran
away with it yeah by the way chess Bay
said that you're lying cuz that you're
she's the only name that you know and
that's what shows that is not true chess
BAE I know lots of other names you're
just my favorite okay hey car was the
closest car working a half opener so
only beat hit Carl by four games which
is something I love her that's an only
right I get it we always thought that
car as being like the best online blitz
player of all time and you know he only
managed to beat in my four but in this
position Danny I mean this is a weird
position with the Queen's in the a file
yep
very close white can go D for it at any
moment well I should know you to get the
clean off the these guys are doing
everything they can to get the Lopez
type is okay this isn't a Lopez but
anything with pawn tension whatever I
feel like we've seen this type of
maneuvering game critical components
being you know whatever happens with the
pawn tension we're gonna see with d4 in
the a pond where where the minor pieces
placed themselves so this is again a
very maneuvering type of game here d4
and the a pawn sounds like a new bent d4
in the a pawns right yep I almost said
something I really would rather I'm
worried about you today I don't know
what's wrong with me you know what I'm a
little tired there's been a lot of
speech as matches
and been going to a lot of therapy
looking at looking for more
opportunities to air out my craziness
but we're having a blast here thanks to
all 15,000 of you who are watching us
whether you're on twitch TV slash chess
or chest comm TV Magnus Carlsen put on a
show and we haven't really talked a lot
about this today Robert but the stats
don't lie right we talked about Magnus
Carlsen being predicted to win this
match by 10 games or more and fun fact
he's well on his way along with us a
specific segment segment predictions
right there so for those of you who
wonder sometimes why that's a fun thing
to highlight when the numbers say that
someone else is just gonna win by a lot
well sometimes the truth hurts that's
the first thing but you know I think
from an odds perspective the more we
provide insights into what we know these
guys are capable of in different
circumstances the more that gives us the
future as in the chess community too to
add other elements and have a lot of fun
making predictions and you know and and
and getting getting more analysis I
really like Roberts idea of time of
possession because I think this has been
a match where Krisha once again by the
way slightly better in this position has
been better most the match for given how
many decisive results have gone against
him today Robert that's a super
interesting point and a very that's you
know that is that's a telling fact of
what you and I've been saying that he's
losing games under time pressure because
the majority of the game he's playing
very well isn't he's just going up a
pawn here yeah he worshipped bishops
going up opponent Magnus is shaking his
head I I'm not looking at the players
but I'm just you know looking the board
and all of a sudden ePHI pawn is just
gone so Bishop d6 that move that Magnus
just played I guess he forgot about pawn
takes a5 first distracting the bishop
from the diagonal and then taking upon
me five so so looking really good for
Greek here but I feel like we've seen
this one before well deep all right well
Magnus is gonna do the thing he does
he's gonna go for something practical
shoutout to smarter chess who just
subscribed to the twitch TV slash chess
channel here comes d4 because rook takes
d4 possible row takes d4 it looks good I
would probably just take f6 even I don't
even know
I mean now route 64 is probably rook
takes defensive winds a clean pawn
that's a clay chase before it loses to
Queen takes e3 so I'm like okay I don't
want to just hang it hang the board so
yeah there's route before that's a free
pawn no transmitted diseases coming
along with it it's over oh boy Teddy
you're so ridiculous
oh gosh anyway the problem though for y
is that you couldn't move the rook
because ninety three was hanging with
check so now black is up and exchanged
but for the price of two pawns and a
very exposed King so rook e1 here for
example should be yep there it is rook
e1 and then I mean just look at the
black King side right if the bishop goes
f7 Knight g4 is really annoying
yep here we go violence Grichuk
grayish it didn't Sasha Grichuk take two
of three at least against Levon Aronian
and air blitz match from last year so I
feel like Grichuk Grichuk has a good
record in chess960 if he wins this game
that's it that's a - OH - OH results so
far in the in the Fischer random portion
and he's on his way to doing a Bishop h4
looks fun
Queen f4 looks delicioso Dora there you
go Knight f5 let's let's uh let's go
with the brute force method 9 H 6 now
undermined the night on g8 and open up
the bishop against the king yep Grichuk
sees it and we're gonna get a big win
for grishnack which he needs to bring
this match to six games I mean I'm
predicting a little early but hey that's
what we do is predict things and then be
wrong you've been doing that for a long
time yeah but I think we're correct here
because the black king is is not safe
the white king is perfectly safe and
white he's also currently up two pawns
so hard to imagine black surviving this
though but we might Magnus do it before
right Oh too many times account too many
times oh I mean III had I literally had
nightmares about rook takes G seven from
in the match with Wesley so I literally
I mean it was just nutty that Magnus was
able to do what he did there couldn't
lose
so now honestly he's making this a
little bit of a mess I guess grishnack
is just gonna go with the simple
approach yeah and it's gonna night back
to g4 rook to e3 yeah
maintain the two-point edge and it
should be a check is also possible here
Nike for I don't think 94 was the best
way to handle that now yes - if he has
to play Brooke a1 is he gonna run into
Bishop takes e4 F takes and rook III and
actually white is headed into a rook
ending instead of what you normally want
with the knight on the board Wow
Grichuk found a way to make this not so
easy to win yeah I mean now all of a
sudden you have you're stuck is the
two-on-one I'm just purely the G and H
files is not that helpful but the you
know the e pawn was gone of course is
not winning with the e pawn I believe it
should be we should be winning but it's
very difficult because you know you
gotta keep that rook attached to upon
there so not not well played by Grichuk
yeah and this is this is you already
highlighted and again from an
instructional perspective this is the
ideal defensive setup the rook is behind
the one and only passed pawn and
therefore actively able to disrupt and
create threats against the opponent
that's really important because if your
book is in front of the pawn your scope
gets smaller with every pawn advance
when your rook is behind the pawn your
rook scope increases with every pawn
advance and that allows you to do things
like this which of course is keeping the
White King trapped in the corner so I'm
gonna say right now it looks like Magnus
may be holding a draw and what was a
losing position for sure I mean this is
okay I mean grishnak I guess is still
he's still poking and prodding no I'm
just king of five and you can even take
on the king of five and even the King
and pawn ending is I think Magnus Magnus
is probably calculating that right now
because that's a big decision if you're
gonna commit to the King upon heading
all right well he calculated it we'll
see is he doing it he's doing it he's
doing it doing it and doing it and doing
it well who said that ll oh my gosh that
runt
hello Cool J you remember that guy I
know who I love Cool J's I just got very
here's what you're doing so have a
somebody balling at LL Cool J song
Robert earlier is Busta Rhymes now it's
hella Cool J it's ma'am and M in there
you're going back going back today I
told you I woke up real early this
morning good good just wonder what just
happened
Magnus what'd he do he played King F
safe how is this a draw Ben did we just
think it was a draw and it wasn't that's
possible King D for king of six Magnus
is looking at the position - Oh was it
just not a draw the whole time no
thinking but yes no yeah I guess it was
it was not a draw huh huh we'll all be
alright we're as confused as you are
Magnus that's a highlight
that's a low-light for everybody there
that was weird right
I guess just totally yeah that I think
was winning the whole time I just kind
of assumed that cuz max was doing it
that should be a draw but whoops
whoopsie whoopsie either way we are
gonna be headed into the 1:1 portion
with Magnus Carlsen in complete control
a six-game lead in the match despite
despite an odd ending to the chess960
game but Grichuk does grab a 2o score in
the chess960 and maintains one of the
best records we have on the format so
Robert it's bullet we've seen Magnus put
on a show before but stranger things
have happened then then an underdog
coming back in a bullet match but what
do you expect to go down here as the as
the fastest segment of our show takes
off in about two minutes
well Magnus is the demo Gorgon you said
stranger things so I gotta give a
shout-out to that show but you know
Magazine vincible somehow like yeah he
blundered this game and you know he's
had many positions that haven't been
good but he just he's just so fast
he's accurate when it counts and Erick
hasn't been so I think that what's a six
point lead
right now for Magnus 6.0 right the score
of 11 and a half it's gonna end up at 10
points yep I do want to go back to this
because you know we have a break and
let's provide some more instruction well
we have 15,000 people watching so this
is this is an interesting moment
everybody because the reason Magnus took
his time here we were talking about that
you see he went from a minute in 3
seconds down to 48 he was really trying
to assess because if you're drawing in a
brook anything the last thing you want
to do is make a transition into a loss
King and pawn ending and very often
amateur or low rated players do that too
quickly they just kind of assume Oh more
active King like I can get away with
this as a draw but what's interesting is
even with that even the world champion
can miss assess those transitions right
Robert what do you think it was that he
miscalculated about about this
transition - he just missed the eventual
idea we saw which was pretty clear white
white does a little flanking action
flanking everybody is when you take
opposition and regardless of what
direction he goes you take the square
that he's given up and you win is is
that he just simply missed this king
before idea you think yeah I think
perhaps he yeah and think that is
exactly what he missed it the king is
actually running over to the center of
the board and kind of shouldering off
the black king once the king as we saw
in the game on 4-h for the final move
the King goes the e6 King g5 or scoops
up the H pawn qg6 the King goes to e5
and again will shoulder that black King
out from the protection of the h5 pawn
so yeah I think you know in which you
know I guess was a difficult drawing I
did with drawing chance of huge uphill
battle he must've thought this was just
a drawing
clearly we missed it as well so
sometimes when you're making those
transitions you focus on the things you
think you can control you're like well I
can get this position with the Kings and
if they play g4 I know I can draw
because my Kings more active and it's
easy to miss something like that but
okay an instructional moment there even
the world champion making a mistake
perhaps a clippable moment if you're
watching this please on our chess
channel maybe highlight that Kingdom
pawn endings are some of the most
important things for people to master
not just so you can brag to your friends
like I'm the King opponent in my liver
but because it allows you to make better
decisions in those practical rook
endings knight endings bishop endings
can you make the trade and draw or win
those endings you don't really know if
you can without knowledge of those
technic
King component ideas and you see you
know Robert I think sometimes you and I
assumed that Magnus is making the right
decision so we're not even assessing
we're like okay he decides he can draw
he goes for this and all the sudden in
hindsight were like wait a second that
was just a horrible decision very rare
but happens
yeah and earlier in the match I was
definitely being more critical I think I
just decided okay it's nothing piece on
the board I trust the world champion but
I always got to be figured for yourself
and in these positions and speaking of
thinking for yourself we shook out to an
early time advantage though that might
you might lose that right and a couple
moves here but this be six sacrifices
thematic trying to ruin the black Queen
side pawn structure keep the bishop on
c8 so you can't go you know pawn b7 to
b6 in the bishop to b7 but I don't see
how why he's gonna regain that pawn now
what is just simply down upon it's gonna
try to make use of the light squares but
I think the extra pawn is is sufficient
for an advantage for black and yes the
Knights coming into d5 but if I'm black
I'm gonna start considering at the right
moment going g5 and trying to swing that
rook over to the Kings side but maybe as
well I mean if you just look at the the
human aspects of good knight on d5
versus bad Bishop on g7 don't we just
don't we just go bananas for whites
chances here I mean I'll put my Brooke
on b5 I'll put my knight on d5 I love
white yeah now I know white is doing
extremely well I thought and actually
taking on f5 and Queen d5 check already
scooped back up with the pawn so yeah oh
look at this [ __ ] when she's settling
on the light squares yeah this is mrs.
checkers right and white can play rook
b5 sit tight Oh rook you know the rooks
come in the H file so you knew careful
King nobody you it's so is whites rook
right King g2 and white can bring the
rook to the H file it feels like blacks
pieces are much more tied down than
whites at this point so that's true
Eponine n f8 change e8 whatever is king
somewhere eight Queen h7 plate is is
black flipping the script bring the King
to g5 and queen to h7 what okay I don't
like King h6 because it gives white the
time to take on b7 shilling King to the
back rank yeah but now Queen h7 doesn't
come with any threats of rook h2 I see
as bad as they may be six
the move just kind of you know
distracting the situation nice things be
6-minute queen age 7 yeah there it is
and black still has a ton of pressure
coming as he is right over blacks window
yeah bloggers winning cuz King g5 next
and you can't stop me from essentially
meeting you don't talk about mating me
right now it's we're entertaining people
please the there's no counter play here
that's fast okay
Queen age three Queen you know just
check check check mate we talked about a
potential turning of the tides and what
it would take for critic to come back
and win has it begun grishnack wins
that's the way well he wins the chess960
game wins again he's only down by five
when's the last time you saw Magnussen's
two games in a row by the way sorry I
blacked out I'm not sure that that
happens in this in this dimension so
you're right I mean it could be it could
be a really interesting sign of things
to come here we have an evidence gambit
think speaking of exciting openings
let's hope that this bullet match
continues to to be nutty yeah this this
already looks great black because now
tonight again I was about to say it beat
me to 95 and now you could take on beast
6 without sacrificing a pawn so you get
the two bishops and ruin blacks Queen
side pawn structure so for the record
deal until that last loss
Magnus hadn't lost a single game in the
match outside of chess960 until that
last loss Robert and bullet Magnus
Magnus hadn't lost any of the classical
games Wow well fun fact about the Evans
gambit Robert I have to say is that
garry kasparov
actually showed his his famous Evans
gambit win over Vichy and on in the
master class and those of us who have a
sneak preview to Garry Kasparov's
masterclass course we know that Robert
do you did you watch it
nope okay come on I gave you a sneak
preview yeah I know but anyway here it
was seriously guys garry kasparov showed
his win over and on and it was a huge
huge game in his career so this will be
fun
see another Evans gambit although this
looks like an Evans gambit gone gone
totally crazy some totally I wanted to
play Brooke g3 there that's what I
wanted but it was bad so I did that
would be that would be awesome to see
but yeah very bad really great idea just
kind of cutting off the Queen of
protection to e5 but even Queen h1 check
trading the Queen's off and then take on
g3 was good for black but here I think
Magus has played Bishop g6 because if
you move the knight then the e5 pawn
falls do your queen h1 okay now where's
Trey Queens in f1 whoa Queen takes f3
dude there should be two you trade
everything trade everything and then
black is gonna lose the pawn right back
on e5 and with that White's gonna have a
much much better ending there's a lot of
pawns over here on the Queen side
everybody a lot of them how many one two
five over there yeah I've I didn't know
you were gonna make me count but okay
black is trying to draw this end game
unless White's King gets himself mated
here with the rook and Knight if Magnus
can pull a Magnus and get a swindle that
would be that would be the way that
black saves this endgame Girish like
handling himself in bullet right now
here comes rook a to though if d3
happens look for Magnus to swing the
rook a4 is gonna fall well anyone yes I
think White's too quick here yeah rook a
feint nice still rook 8 you should have
been played maybe but okay go over to h8
r h7 whatever and then go D 67 King III
here game over okay bro k - he still has
91 check coming but the [ __ ] 26 covers
h2 so now that is that is irritating
agreed yeah I think Rick are we talking
three wins in a row your sugars the man
right now
rook is uh ladies mojo similar to uh
Austin Powers I mean
Stella just got her groove back look at
my max I'm really pumped because
honestly for a while I got hard because
the match was so one-sided and this is
making me much more
to the meso I mean all right madness
could be on Tilly's are three straight
games and you know that is I mean
unheard of for a player of magaz caliber
so we see a French from Greece shooken
is GTF six line even in classical time
patrols sometimes very difficult for
white to keep that initiative going and
then you could face the two bishops so a
smart choice for my point of view from
[ __ ] yep and it will end to me anything
that's dynamic unbalanced bishop pair
here versus castles long and weird pawn
this is what you have to do right now
you're still down by four games with 22
minutes to go but if you're watching
this match and your friends left and
thought it was over as soon as Magnus
reached a bullet you might want to call
them and tell them to come back into
then the heat versus of the Spurs when
all the fans left and Miami won that
game so you don't want to be like them
yeah and in their first meet up last
year's speech Chess Championship Carlsen
won the bullet portion by a score of 8
to 1 so he's already lost the first two
games here grishnak is already bested
his performance from last year Robert
and look at his pawns in the center I
mean he's just really going for it he
can just end up castling he can bring
you know at some point you have to be
careful because f3 or g4 is just gonna
break open the position for for white
but again the bishop on the dark squares
could be quite valuable
given the current circumstance but look
how underdeveloped black because I loved
lux position earlier I feel like things
did not go right because look at the
knight MBA can't get out but just wanna
be said even if you capture an a4 that I
wasn't hurt white whatsoever so the only
oh well you know I mean they didn't know
what else to do to get the knight
developed so he had to give up the white
squares but you're right this I'm not
starting to like black again they saying
like really another sacrifice to open up
more dark squares that is how you work
it everybody you got to open up activity
for your piece before I take C for that
nine to five is hangs you can't take
with the Queen this is over 964 just
crushes white nice the mana flag we'll
see if brochure can find it he doesn't
find it he misses a win
Grichuk was winning on the spot with
Knight takes e4 he misses the shot and
that could be one that comes back too
on him if he doesn't win another game
here this is 25 seconds on the clock so
that's not gonna help either White has
all kinds of threats here white chooses
to take a six there was also ideas like
swinging to the Kings side moves like
Knight h6 so remains unclear but Carlson
has gotten away with one as far as that
that opportunity Grichuk had earlier
maybe still got pressure here he's got
pressure on the dark squares d for
coming here comes the Knight to d5 and
Knight to c3 I like blacks chances no I
don't like blacks chances the bishop
comes to d3 and it's over why not Bishop
d3 that was lights out but now oh wait
what Queen B Tzu's ok so what's going on
here III was lights out a move before by
by Magnus I think anyway ok well we
should get encountered play but not a
lot of time living off the increment
Queen d8 is gonna be making all about
rook g2 or yeah or this way okay that's
a huge huge win for Magnus everybody
stops the bleeding almost went down four
games in a row I don't know if Magnus
has ever lost four games in a row so
huge win there from the world champion
to bounce back and push his lead back to
five games Robert yeah that was really I
mean this Knight 64 the Queen was
overloaded indeed Theresa couldn't take
on c4 because the f5 was hit Knight was
hanging but a huge escape there for
Magnus me to be fair he was probably
better before overlooking that in the
first place but you know if you're sure
you gotta find those things because
otherwise you're just going down yeah
it's so weird it was like he worked so
hard to open up the dark squares make
really timely pawn sacks and then and
then miss the knockout blow so okay it's
a close match though either way 18
minutes and 52 seconds left on the game
clock plenty of time if you keep winning
games like you have so far as grishnack
and the bull abortion I loved before by
the way love at Queen d2 yep Queen d2
very nice very thematic just saying okay
please take me on before and open the a
file because I 90 seconds Bishop d3 this
is how you do it maintain the tension
everybody don't break the tension
build on that tension too you can cut it
with a knife or or whatever Bobby has
likes there yeah take up now take up
1194 take advantage of the pin if you're
Creek pop a pony into e6 no yeah you're
on fire right now 94 was a really nice
move heading to e6
if only I could listen to you I've
always been popping pony since I was
five years old buddy you just you just
send me out for just so many
inappropriate comments oh okay c5 is a
thematic break aiming for this pawn be
five but now ninety-four comes takes
takes Bishop takes a six looked possible
but I don't know rumors have it that the
only time Magnus ever lost four in a row
at anything was playing Chuck Norris in
a game of rock-paper-scissors and his
hand cramped up and he accidentally
played rock 12 times in a row today
remember when we used to play rock paper
scissor that was pretty fun I actually
have figured out kind of the secret to
rock paper scissors as far as the
psychology but that's another tale for
another okay so for you I like that way
up on straight up I think Matt was one
did he put his bishop on a five getting
that on that for no longer his protected
now he's gonna get the exchange but
White's got a lot of pawns for it here
comes b5 and b6 me like Dan you're gonna
love that knight on b8 going absolutely
nowhere to pawns
that's that our own development that
would make Karpov proud to beat go b6
right than that
Queen B 3 B reps b6 is coming we're not
going anywhere
I think Richard I think Grichuk strikes
again continues to put pressure on
Magnus and says the bullet is not gonna
bring a free segment this time pretty
shocking look at that f4 is going gonna
go f5 go cement the night
well Grichuk did eventually deliver on
my prophecy of a night landing on e6 and
i think yeah this is this is this is a
turnaround
Grichuk is up on time winning every game
could have and should have won the last
game
Carles speed like how many times that
move like six times gone nowhere yeah
this is ugly
take the Paulette what happened here
Magnus is down on time now yeah magazine
c7 give me a Queen c7 do it yup there it
is game over wow man was getting crushed
in the bullet section so far so where's
that plus B furger shook and bullet plus
three plus it's plus two right you know
he won the first two games because it
was chess960 so he's plus two right now
right sound yeah that sounds right so
he's plus two in the bullet which is
shocking because I mean everyone was in
awe of Carlson's bullet since last
year's win over Nakamura little Grisham
is I mean I'm shocked I'm in shock right
now but I'm excited I'm excited this is
this is it right this is game on and the
crowds going wild rowdy is going wild
right you see I'll sing get crushed like
this Carlson did lose the bullet portion
to Nakamura by the way five four I mean
okay it was Nakamura but yes he crushed
Grichuk last time eight to one when they
played bullet and I mean a car actually
I mean okay he used to get through
surgery cardiac and that's a huge match
up but a car must be very happy to see
that Magnus Carlsen is not so invincible
in a bullet right now that's really
control that hey car was really renowned
for so all right so far in this game
it looks like white is doing very well
because I pin on the c5 Knight is really
annoying to deal with Knight a four is
gonna be a threat but even if white caps
on c5 I guess it's not that easy to get
to the c5 I still like white here oh I
love white yep okay nevermind c5 pawn is
pretty easy to get to
so G 5 here F 3 at some point this is
getting a little unclear a little
uncomfortable oh I guess F 3 first might
have been better than because it would
have forced the bishop away to H 1 then
he could win G 5/3 and queen h5 so he's
gonna have to close the king side or
else get checkmated but if he does so
why should be winning I mean this is
kind of okay right practical decision
even though it's probably totally
unsound you got to go for it if your
Grichuk and then a smart decision backed
by carlson to give up the brook and try
to shut down the light squares yep
smart decision by you to shut your
window so that that alarm didn't get to
love my windows are shot but I'm in New
York City and that's why I said your
windows are shut smart decision but you
I know it's hard for you to realize when
I'm giving you a compliment but hey it
happens happens frequently that I just
don't know Bishop g4 or 94 but Bishop c4
is okay again Grichuk is doing what you
need to do here people he's just making
open lines keeping it tactical hoping
for the opportunity of a bullet blunder
it happens to the best of them
this is this looks like a pretty clear
loss here for for black who has nothing
white it's just a matter of time before
moves like Bishop I was gonna say Bishop
a5 there was even nasty but this also
works white piece and the only one who
can win Grichuk needs to resign he needs
to resign and play into the game he's
smart he knows match strategy don't keep
playing this one on Sasha okay I think
he's gonna realize it here in a second
resigns and with that he resigns twelve
and a half minutes to go in the total
game clock and this one is gonna come
down to the seconds and the wires if
grocer can keep winning some of these
games here the Evans gambit garry
kasparov masterclass our sponsor of the
2007 TSP chess championship check it out
see Gary's a review of his epic win over
Vichy and on from their world
championship match in the Evans gambit I
always hate positions for blah
like I see don't like why doesn't the
Evans gambit get played more I mean
seriously right I love it no it's fun
it's very saucy as you would say but
assessing sassy is what the cool kids
say Roberts saucy is what is what bros
try to say who would think they're cool
but that's why you saw snows that's why
you just said saucy okay okay whatever
anyway I think eight eight straight
games have been decisive so we you know
that's that's draws and grow shook is
once again down by five and you said
there are twelve minutes left
approximately so yeah now eleven and a
half minutes left racing against the
game clock they are hashtag Yoda so now
this on black is just doing extremely
well right black is up a pawn here this
week see pawn
there's no attack on the kingside so you
know like on Knight h5 here pretty
somatic Y so I'll suddenly hate White's
position a lot well I mean despite you
you liking a relaxed position in this
situation I don't want to remind you of
of your own loss in this in this Evans
gambit in a famous event do you want to
ring it up now or later you might lost a
a car why did you have to do that well
because it was instructive from the
perspective that you've also felt the
pain that Carlson's feeling right now
it's getting getting beaten in the Evans
gambit Carl firstly I was black in that
game I lost and Carlson's better no I
was doesn't I'm saying you were black in
that game like Magnus is and I think I
think critics gonna get it why do you
think we're just gonna get it I don't
know he's down like a zillion pawn he's
gonna play Brooksie to rook c1 we love
the Evans gambit here and then d5 and I
just protect my night so I know you're
talking about or I wish I wish you were
correct
I also wish all right Knight III comes
for black oh I thought Magnus will play
93 and simplify isn't 92 just good for
white no no 92 rook c8 trade-ins
on c4 Bunch time to take on b7 this
isn't a bad idea though and also I mean
Grichuk is gonna have a meeting net if
he can somehow get a rook in a night
together over here
against the black king that night on f5
is super sassy h4 h5 cement that nights
position may be started king f2 yeah
just to avoid okay but now Carlson says
no thank you
so that night in h4 is looking real good
King 816 g5 yeah yeah in case you didn't
catch that everybody that was Robert has
his favorite form of humor known as
sarcasm that not any for is not looking
good uh sometimes sarcasm isn't noticed
so I have to clarify all right Magnus is
gonna win the King and pawn ending
mainly because he gets a queen and gets
all the pawns with it so uh what's the
easiest Road here probably also could've
just gobbled the h3 pawn but this region
traded my voice there was claw yeah I
didn't see that yep if King b7 everybody
Queen d5 if it came to the D file Queen
d5 so it was just over well you know
what honestly that was the that was the
world champion doing what I needed to do
Robert that was him rebounding regrab
exceed and honestly clinching the match
with it I mean that that's I think
that's pretty much it
what's the computer Chess Championship
because he played this line in the
exchange French that we saw one of our
favorite openings ever right yeah but I
mean this was played a number of times
in the you know in the computer Chess
Championship so Magnus must have had his
eyes on the on those tournament well we
gotta ask Magnus how he was feeling as
Grichuk went on a run there in Bullitt
and uh and how he rebounded right so
interesting decision ok giving up the b7
pawn because Queen b7 b8 and then
there's no Queen six a six because
Bishop H takes H you check except the
Queen
so Queen a7 and Queen c8 and I think the
Queen's trapped over on a7 so not a good
look for Magnus right now
now just losing this yeah I think he's
no-go queen c8 a little frustrated queen
c8 maybe White has d5 getting the Queen
out then I go Bishop c5 not figure out
my lady
there you go Sasha very nice Sasha you
found it so much easier to do Compton in
play I mean just unbelievable you know
what it's unbelievable
so Brooke do I take on I'm sick GFC take
off six okay he's gonna okay it makes
sense another way to skin that cat black
has the Queen and should be pretty
easily winning here an endgame with
enough pawn weaknesses on both sides of
the board let's the Queen do what she
does bounce around and just outplay the
pieces who can't collect coordinating
time yep so the worst thing that could
happen for black is it the Knights the
two white knights he traded for the
bischmann nine that Bishop stays on e5
that would not be good look yep there
goes c5 that was a nice little
transition there by Grishka queen c6
queen b5 what tempo I was thought I
thought maybe for a second he was
blundering c7 but but indeed I was wrong
big surprise there okay but this is
really nice because his Robert was
saying what you don't want is to is to
trade off everything but the bishop and
the rook that would let white get what
they need with rook c7 although now he's
but well it's worth noting as I'm being
told that joke is owing to in games
where he has the extra Queen so that's
not a not a good sign for Rick here yeah
that's a that's what that sounds like a
Mike clients tab right there stop my
wine Mac my client did inform me of that
so good on him the 196th okay I don't
see how black is gonna is just winning
here yeah I agree the counter play has
has arrived and all and now with no more
tart I mean this is exactly what I was
trying to say in the beginning why the
Queen was better everybody because there
were targets
both sides of the board so the black
queen could outmaneuver an outplay but
now now there's only play on one side of
the board so unless he swindled some
sort of checkmate here this is exactly
how the pieces can not only hang with
the Queen but have those rare scenarios
where they can help player so now I'm
left eye there's a queen c6 here for
example would have been very tricky so
I'm not even sure who's better if anyone
is better but yeah it may not end in a
draw them because of that
I mean Grichuk wants more than a draw as
he is as he needs and it is required to
go for but this is this has not gone
well I think I think this initial plan
we applauded with c5 maybe maybe
wouldn't have been as good as just
trading off that Bishop originally for
the night Queen d5 check okay and Monica
does blunder he does wonder if Queen e2
check comes and crisis work your way out
and you win the bishop in black words
mix why Carlsen that went away Magnus
had it he had he had he had things going
where he wanted shout out to master lief
feed a master title player playing guest
the move who just won that round with 35
out of 77 so first of all kudos you for
guessing on 77 moves I mean that's
pretty awesome
but last chance to play guess to move
everybody you can log on to choice comm
so only a few minutes left here we have
just crossed under the four-minute mark
Robert in the match and we will have the
players joining us for interviews so
looks like Magnus Carlsen is going to be
moving on into the next round of the
speech s championship I think we can
pretty much call it here yeah it's
impossible for sauce sugar shook to
catch up with you to the four minutes
left so max just flag the next four
games and still win the match oh
actually in the of the 960 but you get
the point so Magnus moves on Magnus
moves on and it's going to be Magnus
Carlsen in the finals while we await the
matchup within a couple weeks of Sergei
Kuryakin and Hikaru Nakamura so make
sure you are staying tuned to chest
komm TV and all of our news sections at
chest comm slash news as we make the
announcement of that date official we've
already talked about it being
tentatively planned for December 15th
Nakamura versus cardiac and it's going
down that's the 10th straight game with
no draws fYI that last that last game so
lots of decisive chess here to end the
day gives uh gives the fans what they
want right lots of winning games makes
Jack a dull boy wait that doesn't make
sense didn't make any sense but this
position also looks exciting because
black is about to try to go d4 if like
Bishop c5 you can sit of going d4 and
sacrificing some material and now white
is trying to okay now pieces are coming
off the board I guess not rook c8 should
be a draw yeah Bishop e6 [ __ ] hope we're
not no wait now that he's allowed Bishop
c6 suddenly black actually no I mean
just looking at the past D pawn and
thinking the black has chances here but
I'm likely wrong as usual I would say
black is better but I don't see how to
to get this full point the Bishop d3
here feels like the move okay six that's
also very nice and that's actually
that's actually probably too many
problems for black right there that's
clever that is clever because if black
keeps trying to win my getting up in
trouble Bishop d3 here with eight seven
notes what h4 pawn is falling and now
here comes the beep on b5 keep it going
Girish ik has he's Magnus Magnus in this
game room d7 is a great move because
giving up the a pawn for the past be
pawn much better that be pawn becomes
much closer to queening now everybody
totally worth that exchange ok still
probably should just be a draw but this
has become one of those wacky positions
where it's a draw with like computers
playing easily but humans can make
blunders when both sides have passed
Ahn's and all kinds of weird stuff going
on we'll see if we got a little tickle
here it looks like tickles happening and
rook f4 should be repetition get your
tickle on nope
he wants more than tickle well he wants
less guys about to say that always runs
in the wreckage for wait we should just
lose the game no yeah really I think he
that wasn't the optimal plan of action
there a scientific term less than ideal
I guess Wow
game over that pond screening well
Grichuk may or may not have known that
that this was his last chance to get a
victory it looks like we are officially
moved on the 8 the total game timer
being a few seconds behind our official
judges clock which means chess960 has
started which means we are at the end of
the match and what questions are we
going to have for them as we look at
this super interesting and as always
unique chess960 position well I guess we
have to ask Sasha about you know all
those games where he slipped up or
assimilated great positions and you know
when he got into time trouble it just
wasn't working out for him so there's
definitely that right huh and I well
what do you got in mind I guess we could
ask no I think we can definitely ask
Magnus how he was feeling there of it
that's the most games he's lost in the
bullet portion oh my god he lost they
ready look Dane the King has no moves
what since he made in the center of the
board the sacrifices Queen because they
forgot about Queens I castle slightly
surprising I guess but that means the
match is quickly over where we were not
expecting it to be and we will invite
the players back they are they are here
Matt Magness can you hear us as well
oh hi Magnus hi Sasha
that ended that ended rather abruptly
can you tell us what happened on the D
file there Magnus surprising yeah I just
forgot about the rules sort of us got it
well anyway teasing aside obviously
congratulations you played played a
great match today the bullet portion
there's got a little bit sticky to start
where you were you feeling nervous there
and were you were you surprised by how
the first few bullet games went was
Sasha going on a run no I mean it's just
kind of difficult to play I mean it felt
like my pieces are stuck in mud you know
it's uh well I'm sorry to hear that yeah
we need to yeah so yeah I mean you J
it's yeah the game becomes rather slow
and it's it's sort of hard to get get a
rhythm but okay and anyway yeah I think
I was uh played in the bullet portion
but fortunately I had very big lead so
Sasha was the five-minute portion there
felt like there were there were a few
opportunities with you having a slight
edge sometimes sometimes a clearly
better almost winning position there but
time pressure seemed to be the
difference was it something you were
kind of aware was going on that you were
that you were under time pressure or or
did you have a different thought about
about how the five minute fortune what
yeah thank you yeah I think at the
beginning I played very slow I mean
which is which almost equals to very but
I mean I mean it's impossible to play so
slow I mean I just could not calculate
any tactics any simple tactics that's
right just to avoid blundering pieces I
was spending so much time but of course
and once you go down two seconds when
you cannot I mean when you are not in a
good form then
you are just a sort of postpone blunders
yeah I mean I've had some probably good
positions but but I think overall Magnus
played very good I mean extremely well
at the beginning in five - Porsche
yeah yeah on the radio after five - it
was I was - four or five it was very
difficult but at least I'm happy that
sort of competed in Bullitt the only
thing is only good to sing for me in
this myth found yourself in the boat
well yeah we definitely apologizing and
we will work on the the feeling of the
of the bullet there Magnus but in
regards to your overall game sorry what
what this happened with Magus was
describing he was struggling with some
of the some of the feel of the of the
pieces and the board that were we need
to work on
that's a chest comp problem we'll work
on but I was gonna say Magnus is the
flipside of griffix of Sasha's time
pressure was you being up on time is
that's something you just come into with
these matches just knowing that even if
you can't solve everything in the moment
you seem to constantly be up on time
against your opponents when it matters
and then if you could maybe talk a
little bit about how you manage your
time throughout these these matches but
I think it's a lot about what session
was talking about that when when you're
feeling good when you're playing well
then you also play much faster so at the
start III think I was playing very well
at least much better than I have been in
my previous matches and then yeah then
it wasn't wasn't so hard to to play fast
but but then yeah when you start to
struggle you kind of slow down and yeah
that's the that's the way it is so yeah
I try not to get in time trouble but
towards the end it was impossible
because I just wasn't thinking
you know very very fast Nagas we were
wondering that you know you just had a
match against Wesley so the other day do
you feel like you were informed because
you followed up a match so quickly with
another I think it's certainly an
advantage and it probably told that to
start yeah you need a little bit more
time to get into it but yeah I mean at
some point in the match it doesn't
matter that much but certainly I had an
advantage at the start I what do you
think about this game where you
sacrifice the cream for that bills
compensation I mean it's a 5-2 I think
it was Sam's and you could hook on a one
attacker hoop on h4 you can kill light
on g5 what do you think it was because I
wondered I just wondered right yeah I
was just lucky that it was not
completely losing yeah yeah we that was
definitely a highlight of my yeah sorry
Sasha that didn't work out but it was we
were debating amongst us whether Magnus
had blundered or not but I think we
could tell from his face that he did
he'd that he didn't see it but yeah it
definitely was an interesting one a lot
of interesting games today thank you
both so much
obviously we'll continue to work on
everything Magnus we really appreciate
both you guys being great in our
interview here and Robert any final
questions for our players before we ask
Magnus how he thinks the cardiac and
Nakamura match will go yeah one last
question for Sasha Sasha you just saw a
beast at the 960 chest that's something
you specifically work on and just feel
like you have a natural knack for that
that form of chest you know but I mean
it's just luck I mean at least this much
okay just last game I mean that's what
you need to know about my chest well you
did go three you know in the chess960 so
a take away there as far as the match
goes but Magnus Sergey Karjakin takes on
a core Nakamura it's going to be an
exciting one
we think and and and and very close
despite Hikaru's online beastly Blitzen
bullet reputation how do you see those
two players matching up with what we
think at karo having a big edge in the
bulletin and then the khari Aachen maybe
having a slight edge in some of the
Blitz but how do you see those two
players going at it well first of all
when is it gonna be the the plan right
now is December 15th mid December
okay okay so it's a long long time
unfortunately yeah with we had a the
Grand Prix and then the London tornado I
don't know I think he car is obviously a
favorite but Sergei was very very good
in much with Jung last time out so so
you never know but I wouldn't bet
against Sagara that's for sure
all right well thank you we're all
excited so who are you betting on that I
mean I don't think who's that cadet Kim
is an extremely close maybe
yeah he's become very good at puts all
right well we will see obviously it's
it's more more it's longer away than
anybody wants including Magnus and the
fans but very very busy global chess
schedules these days so thank you both
Sasha
congratulations on getting this far
beating Maxine by Shayla Grove and sorry
I didn't work out today but best of luck
next year and Magnus thank you once
again for for entertaining all of us and
we'll see you in the finals thank you
all right well we there you have it we
have the final comments there from
Magnus and Sasha your your final
comments before we move on and and get
set for the next match where's the guy
just say how much I love Sasha Grisha
he's he's the best post match interview
win or lose he is just awesome and I he
just went right into the chest you know
from a game from like the beginning of
the match and none of us were thinking
about right and he's such a nice guy
he's a great competitor so I think it
just goes to show how
strong Magnus's that he was able to take
out Grisha goodness in this fashion and
with such a you know a big
differentially or five points is a lot
when you're facing Sasha go should but I
Danny you know if crochet wasn't a
different side of the bracket didn't
have to play Magnus potentially till the
final he never know he could make it all
the way so really strong competitor I
was impressed by his play I think he
just wasn't in the right state of mind
today he was blundering at inopportune
moments and magnus carlsen to his credit
played some really good chess as a
Grisha committee as well yep well agree
to hundred percent and I can't wait to
see what happens in the next matchup
between Corey Aachen and Nakamura and I
love when top players tend to disagree
on who the favorite is because I think
it keeps all the rest of us who don't
know these players as well as as
Magnuson and Sasha do right on the edge
of our seats in regards to who might win
that match so also really fun to note
that Sasha over performed our
statistical modules predictions which is
awesome we love being wrong because that
gives us an opportunity to get better
and today
Sasha even though he was he was given a
line of ten games he only lost the match
by five and really really performed
incredibly well against Magnus despite
like I think everyone agreed he started
slow made some blunders in the
five-minute portion was constantly under
time pressure which is we highlighted as
usually a sign of being out of form out
of shape and yeah definitely definitely
interesting to note that Magnus may have
benefited greatly from just having a
match a few days ago versus so-so great
stuff
either way we thank everybody for being
here all uh more than 15,000 of you at
the peak a peak viewership don't even
have any idea how many of you are still
here but me and Grand Master Robert Hess
signing off for the two of us and
sending you out one more reminder that
you have to go and sign up at
masterclass comm slash chest check out
Garry Kasparov scores sign up for it
just calm members you can now get the
full master class from Garry Kasparov it
is available go get it and here's your
here's your final sneak peek from our
sponsors of the 2017 SP Chess
Championship I'm here to share with you
my knowledge of the game
it's not just checks and attacks you
have to create check and now we can look
at few studies when changing pieces
could lead to a decided Vantage for one
side or to be a defensive mechanism to
save the game that looks otherwise
desperate why does an extra piece but
our pool is under attack and our mite is
under attack in the middle game or in
the opening you definitely have to pay
attention to this threat because Knight
is more valuable at a pawn but with an
endgame
so protecting the knight doesn't do us
any good if we protect the night and
black takes the pawn that's a serrated
wrong position rook and Knight cannot
win against alone but how can we benefit
from keeping this pawn alive a trick is
that we play quiet move a three
it doesn't seem logical black simply
takes the knight with a check but then
king b2 and surprise surprise the rook
there are so many moves cannot avoid the
exchange frogs goes back on h1 or g1 the
loop d1 will change rooks and our poem
is unstoppable but instead of moving to
first rank
h1z1 like who can go back to a4 and then
we understand why our poor moved down to
F to a three sometimes very important
you make just a small move one square
but
it has devastating effect because this
poem protects square before and after
hoop III check King goes on c2 or a -
doesn't matter
the loup-garou before and rook black
rook is trapped technically is not
trapped because like an exchangeable
either taking one before and after a
before our pawn is unstoppable or moving
grew kanji for and then after exchange
our pawn is again stopped and that's one
of the lessons of this endgame